I'M
CALLING ALL THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO COME TO THE
MEANING IT'S A LITTLE PAST NINE
O'CLOCK WE WOULD LIKE TO START
ON TIME- WE HAVE MEMBERS HERE
THAT ARE HERE RIGHT NOW READY
TO- GIVE TESTIMONY ON TIME AND
WE SHOULD A- BE COGNISANT OF
THEIR TIME TO. SO ONLY BE A FEW
MORE MINUTES AND WE HOPE WE GET
TO A POOR. BUT IN THE MEANTIME-
BEFORE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
AS IS OUR CUSTOM SINCE COVERED-
BY. WILL WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE UNTIL WE GET TO A CAR
WITH WILL CALL THE ROLL- BUT I
NEED TO READ THE CULPRIT.
ADMONISHMENTS WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AT EIGHT P. S. F. DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOP. PLEASE NOTE THAT
ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED
TO THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAYBE READ
INTO THE RECORD OR REPRINTED.
ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE
HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM OF
THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE W. W. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOP SLASH
TODAY'S EVENT- ROOM WILL OPEN
FOR ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING A HEARING IS
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES WHILE IN THE BUILDING. THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO PARTICIPATE IN
HIS HEARING BY TELEPHONE WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
TO COMMITTEES WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES. AND WITH THAT. THE
OTHER HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS- WE
HAVE. UP FOR DAYS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK STONE FILLING IN FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PERK. FOR
COMMITTEE THIS WEEK. BOB
CALENDAR WE HAVE THE FOLLOWING-
MEMBERS HAVE PULLED THEIR ITEM
FROM THE CALENDAR DAYS
CALENDARS. ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
A. B. SIXTEEN OH THREE ONE SIX
OH THREE SALAS STAFF SHOPLIFTING
AMOUNT PULLED BY AUTHOR. I TO
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB. ONE FIVE
NINE SEVEN FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN
WALDRON SHOPLIFTED INCREASED
PENALTIES FOR PRIOR CRIMES
PULLED BY AFTER. THE THREE HAVE
TWO MEMBERS HERE AND WE HAVE A
MEMBER READY TO TESTIFY WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN BECAUSE I KNOW WE
HAVE OTHER MEMBERS THAT HAVE
SOME SOME HARD TIMES UNION NEED
TO START SO MISTER BENNETT YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I ON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OUR
COUNTRY'S LIVING THROUGH A GUN
VIOLENCE CRISIS OF EPIDEMIC
PROPORTIONS WITH TENS OF
THOUSANDS KILLED EVERY YEAR AND
MANY MORE WOUNDED. OVER THE
COURSE OF OUR LIFETIMES I
BELIEVE EVERY AMERICAN WILL KNOW
SOMEONE WHO LOSES THEIR LIFE TO
GUN VIOLENCE. THIS IS UNIQUELY
AMERICAN PHENOMENON AND THE
QUESTION IS WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING SO MUCH MORE IN
AMERICA THAN EVER EVERY PLACE
ELSE. WHY DOES VIRTUALLY EVERY
OTHER FIRST WORLD COUNTRY HAVE
SO MUCH LESS GUN VIOLENCE IT'S
PREPOSTEROUS TO THINK THAT ALL
OF THESE OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE. I THINK THE REASON IS
OBVIOUS WE HAVE THE WEAKEST GUN
CONTROL BILLS THE STRONGEST GUN
LOBBY AND THE MOST PERVASIVE GUN
CULTURE IN THE FIRST WORLD. IN
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA SOLVE
TROUBLING RISE OF MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED HOMICIDES WHICH IS THE
LARGEST JUMP IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY SINCE RECORD KEEPING
BEGAN IN NINETEEN SIXTY.
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE STATE
RECORDED MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND HANDGUN
TRANSACTIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY.
UP 65% FROM THE PRIOR YEAR. GUN
SHOWS ARE DEDICATED EVENTS TO
DISPLAY AND SALE OF FIREARMS AND
FIREARM RELATED ACCESSORIES
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ATTEND GUN
SHOWS HELD EACH YEAR
CONTRIBUTING TO A GROWING GUN
CULTURE. THAT IS SO CLOSELY
CORRELATED TO THE RISING GUN
VIOLENCE WE ARE EXPERIENCING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. THE PROFITS
EARNED BY GUN MANUFACTURERS HAVE
AN RICH THEIR TOP EXECUTIVES AND
FUNDED THE GROWTH OF THE OF THIS
GUN CULTURE THAT IS SO UNIQUE TO
THE UNITED STATES. WE DON'T NEED
TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR OUT REACH BY
MAKING LARGE PUBLIC VENUES
AVAILABLE FOR GATHERINGS THAT
ADVANCE A GUN CULTURE THAT
ENRICHES THEM AND SHATTERS THE
LIVES OF SO MANY. IT'S TIME TO
END THE PRACTICE OF MAKING THESE
GUNS AVAILABLE AT PUBLICLY OWNED
SITES LIKE OUR FAIRGROUNDS THAT
IN OUR COMMUNITY IN PARTICULAR.
WHICH THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES. IS WHERE OUR
COMMUNITY GOES FOR RECREATION
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE FAIR
GROUNDS ALL OF OUR USED
ACTIVITIES MANY OF OUR YOUTH
ACTIVITIES ARE CENTERED AROUND
OUR FAIR GROUNDS. AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY NINE TAKES A SMALL FIRST
STEP IN MY COMMUNITY THAT
SEEKING TO PROHIBIT THE SALE OF
FIREARMS AND FIREARM PICTURES OR
PARTS OR AMMUNITION AT THE
VENTURA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS AND
TO TAKE A SMALL STEP TOWARDS
ENDING THE GROWTH OF THE GUN
CULTURE. WHEN I WAS READING A
BEDTIME STORY TO OUR FIRST
GRADER AND HE ASKED ME IF I
COULD GET TO HIS CLASSROOM IN
TIME TO PROTECT HIM OF A SHOOTER
CAME ON CAMPUS. I HAVE TO TELL
YOU I GULPED HARD THE MAJORITY
OF THE PARENTS IN MY DISTRICT
WANT TO DECREASE THE PRESENCE OF
A GUN CULTURE IN OUR COMMUNITY
THIS IS ONE STEP TO DO THAT.
HERE WITH ME TODAY SPEAKING AT
THE PORT OF THIS BILL IS FORMER
VENTURA COUNTY SUPERVISOR KATHY
LONG WITH VENTURA COUNTY BRADY
AND PIPER BENHAM FROM THE WOMEN
FOR AMERICAN VALUES AND ETHICS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JR. THURMOND
BEGAN WITH THE WITNESSES SUPPORT
WITNESSES DUE TO WITNESSES FIVE
MINUTES TOTAL. THEN THE
REMAINING WILL BE SUPPORT. GIVEN
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION- BY
TELEPHONE OPPOSITION IS SAYING
TO WITNESSES FIVE MINUTES TOTAL.
IN REMAINING TYING FOR PEOPLE
CALLING IN- CHAU. AND THEY WILL
HAVE TO PRESENT WILL BE MAKING
THEIR CLOSING STATEMENTS. WE
CALLED IN WITH QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THEN
CHAIRMAN MAKE. FIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE CLOSING
STATEMENT. SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
WITNESSES READY. WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES SO KATHY LONG ARE YOU
READY. FROM THE VENTURA COUNTY
BRADY BY BY PHONE. I AM CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN GOOD- GOOD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT I AM SPEAKING TODAY OF
THE FORMER VENTURA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR TWENTY METERS A
THIRTY FIVE YEAR RATHER THAN
THAT BURKE COUNTY A MOTHER
ADVOCATE WITHIN THEIR CUNNING
GRADY. WE BEEN WORKING FOR
YEARS. ABOUT UNSPOKEN ARE OUT.
OWN PROPER. WE. THANK
IMPLEMENTED PARK REFLECT IS A
VIRTUAL. WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATE AND
THE FOUNDER OF. THAT ARE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE RESIDENTS OF
THE THIRD PARTY WORK BUT- THE
FACT THAT IT. BARBARO BOB
HERTZBERG ON BLACK COMMITTEE
CLUSTER ARE YOU HAVE A POP YOU
BREAKING UP CAN YOU. IT CLOSER
MOVE AROUND A LITTLE BIT. AIR
LIMITED AFTER THAT BETTER HUH.
OKAY ANYWAY- THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN- AS WAS MENTIONED WE'VE
HAD MASS SHOOTINGS THAT ARE
COUNTY BOARD GOING BY OUR GIRL
IS THE MOST NOTED ONE CULTURE IN
OUR COMMUNITY REALLY MY CHANGES
MUST BE TREATED AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS TO CHANGE THE
PARADIGM OF HOW WE HUMAN BEINGS
WILL ADVANCE SAFER COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE OVER THIRTEEN RETAIL GUN
SHOP IN VENTURA COUNTY PROVIDING
REGISTERED SAFE ACCESS TO
OWNERSHIP OF THE COALITION TO
STOP GUN VIOLENCE UNLIKE
LICENSED GUN STORES BOTH
FEDERALLY LICENSED DEALERS AND
UNLICENSED SELLERS CAN SELL GUNS
AT GUN SHOWS GUN SHOWS ARE NOT A
PROTECTED CLASS IN SHOULDN'T BE
GRANTED THAT STATUS. GUN SHOWS
AT THE FAIRGROUNDS ENHANCE THE
CULTURE. THE GUY BEING- EVERY
DAY EVERY USE- AND BEING AS WAS
. ACTIVE TO DRILLS HAVE BECOME
PART OF OUR CHILD'S REGULAR
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT AND WE NEED
TO CHANGE THAT WHEN YOU STEP UP
AND SPEAK UP TO CHANGE THE
PICTURE OF THIS. YOU CAN'T BRING
NORTH SELL GUNS IN CITY HALL OR
COUNTY BUILDING. WILL SHOULD BE
APPLIED TO ALL TAXPAYER PUBLICLY
OWNED PROPERTIES. WITH OF COURSE
EXCEPTIONS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS. WE REALLY MUST
CHANGE THE CULTURE NO LONGER PUT
PROFITS IN FRONT OF OUR
COMMUNITY TO START AT THE FAIR
GROUNDS THAT CELEBRATE. OUR
YOUTH AND OUR FAMILIES AND NOT
GUN SHOWS. IT IS REALLY
INCUMBENT ON US TO TAKE A STRONG
STATEMENT THAT THIS PUBLIC OWNED
PROPERTY REPRESENTS A MAJORITY
OF OUR RESIDENTS YOU STRIVE FOR
SAFE COMMUNITIES. AND A CULTURE
THAT PROMOTES HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. WITH YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION THE PARADIGM
WILL SHIFT AND WE CAN ALL WORK
TO ADVANCE HEALTHCARE SOCIAL
JUSTICE FOR OUR COMMUNITY. I
THANK YOU FOR THIS TIME. OKAY
AND NOW- PARKER. THE NON ON THE
WAY TESTIFIED. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS PAPER BAN- I AM A MOTHER
OF TWO CHILDREN AND I'M HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE. GUNS ARE
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
CHILDREN UNDER EIGHTEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY. WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION CIVILIAN OWNED FIREARMS
IN THE U. S. MORE GUNS THAN
THERE ARE PEOPLE AND THAT NUMBER
IS ONLY INCREASING. TWENTY
TWENTY RECORDED THE MOST GUN
SALES IN A SINGLE YEAR EVER. IN
CALIFORNIA AND SOMEONE IS KILLED
WITH A GUN EVERY THREE HOURS.
THE HUMAN AND FISCAL HOLE IN HIS
GUN VIOLENCE CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED. A FEW YEARS AGO
THERE WAS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCIDENT IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
DOWN THE STREET FROM MY
DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL. THERE WAS AN
ANGRY BOYFRIEND WITH A GUY THIS
FATHER THE- PROCEDURE TEACHERS
LOCK THEIR- DOORS TURNED OFF THE
LIGHTS AND THE KIDS HAD TO HIDE
UNDER THEIR DESKS. TWENTY
MINUTES PAST WELL NOBODY KNEW IF
THERE WAS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER ON
CAMPUS CIRCUIT WITH THE DROUGHT
. MY DAUGHTER WAS IN FOURTH
GRADE AT THAT TIME HER CLASSROOM
WAS FILLED WITH TERRIFIED TEN
YEAR OLD HIDING IN THE DARK AND
A TEACHER TRYING TO CALM THEM.
PLEADING WITH THEM TO BE QUIET.
IT WAS EXTREMELY TRAUMATIZING
EXPERIENCE FOR THE KIDS THAT
WAS. THREE YEARS AGO AND SHE
STILL TALKS ABOUT IT. NOW I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT BOYFRIEND HAD A
GHOST GUN BY SOMEONE WITH A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RECORDS WOULD
NOT PASS A BACKGROUND CHECK. BUT
EVEN WITH THE PRIOR CRIMINAL
RECORD HE COULD WALK INTO A GUN
SHOW INVITED MANY GOES GUNS AS
HE WANTED CASH AND CARRY. IT'S
INTUITIVE THAT DOMESTIC ABUSERS
SHOULD NOT HAVE EASY ACCESS TO
GUNS BUT THEY DO IN CALIFORNIA.
GHOST GUNS ARE RECOVERED FROM
CRIME SCENES IN INCREASING
NUMBERS THERE ARE A GROWING
PROBLEM FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
WEAPON OF CHOICE FOR. CRIMINALS
OR ANYONE WHO WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO PASS A BACKGROUND CHECK OR IS
UNDER AGE.EITHER UN SERIALIZED
AND UNTRACEABLE GUNS. FLOODING
INTO OUR COMMUNITY AND FUELING
OUR GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC. THE
SHOOTER DOWN THE STREET AT THE
BORDERLINE BAR AND GRILL USED
BANNED HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
THESE MAGAZINES ALLOWED HIM TO
FIRE UNINTERRUPTED WITHOUT
HAVING TO PAUSE TO RELOAD AND
POSSIBLY GIVE HIS VICTIMS THE
CHANCE TO GET AWAY. DID HE BY
THOSE HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINES AT
THE GUN SHOW. HE KILLED THIRTEEN
PEOPLE THAT DAY WE OWE IT TO OUR
CHILDREN TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO STOP THIS SENSELESS GUN
VIOLENCE AND NOW IS THE TIME.
THE GUN SHOW CAN MOVE TO A VENUE
THAT ISN'T OWNED BY THE STATE
AND SUBSIDIZE WITH OUR TAX
DOLLARS I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU
TO ASSEMBLY. ENSURE JOHN SO IT
AND THE COMMITTEE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONES- ARE THERE FOR ME TO.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. ON A
MISTER BENNETT'S BILL AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE. OPERATOR
CAN YOU OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT. OUR
FIRST COMMENT WILL COME FROM A
WIND FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ME JUST A MOMENT. ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINERS PARDON ME. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO NOW TO WHY NOT.
FORTY SIX. HELLO I'M FORTY SIX A
LOT OF FOLKS THE LINE IS. YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
THE CHAIR I APOLOGIZE IT APPEARS
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME CONFUSION
WITH PEOPLE WISHING TO COMMENT
WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO LINE
FORTY SEVEN. I AM FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIR. YOUR YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION SIR WHAT
IT. THEY ARE SEE WHAT BILL IS A
BIT. THIS IS ABC. SEVENTEEN
SIXTY NINE. IS A FIREARMS BILL.
IT MAY NOT BE THE ONE YOU WANT
TO SPEAK GLAD. THEN AGAIN ON THE
ONE ON THE- LINE MAYBE WE'RE
GONNA GO TO APPLYING FOR FIFTY
EIGHT MISTER CHAIR JUST A MOMENT
. AND JUST ANOTHER MOMENT PLACE. ONE FIFTY EIGHT WILL BE WITH
US IN JUST A MOMENT. LINE. FIFTY
EIGHT. BUT YES STARRED ZERO.
PARDON ME ONE LINE TO TAKE YOUR
LONG WINDOW WILL. YOU KNOW GIVE
YOU A NUMBER. WELL NOT YOU'RE
OPEN NOW. YEAH MAIN ANONYMOUS
PLAY. WHY DO YOU HATE YOUR LIFE
NOW. BUT. YEAH AND I APOLOGIZE
WE'RE GOING TO GO LAW SIX THREE
LINE THREE WIND OPEN. WILL BE
RECORDED ON ARE. LAST. BURKE
THERE GENERAL BUT ON LIFE LAID.
MAJOR LINE SIX THREE LINE IS
OPEN PLACE SOUNDS LIKE THE SAME
PER THE UP. YEAH AND PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT MISTER CHERRY I.
JUST A MOMENT. ALL RESOLVE THIS
ISSUE VERY QUICKLY. YEAH OKAY AN
ENEMY ARE ANY MEAT SENSE OF MR
GONNA BILLS THAT ARE IN AUDIENCE
OR IN PUBLIC ARENA RIGHT HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SHE NINE-
MISTER CHAIR PARDON I APOLOGIZE
AGAIN WILL I BELIEVE WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PROCEED WIDE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS PETER STEIN I'M WITH
WAVES AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
THEN I WHOLEHEARTEDLY- ENDORSE
THE TESTIMONY OF THE WITNESSES
THANK THANK YOU. YEAH WE'LL GO
TO LINE SIXTY FIVE. PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO LINE
SEVEN DAY. YOUR CHAIR I
APOLOGIZE IT APPEARS THAT WE MAY
BE HAVING A TECHNICAL ISSUE HERE
IF I MAY JUST A MOMENT. WELL IN
THE MEANTIME AND HOPEFULLY
PEOPLE CAN HEAR ME. UP FOR THE
MEMBERS SAID THAT HAVE COME-
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN ESTABLISH A
CORN RIGHT NOW. I'M SURE MISTER
BENNETT WILL WANT US TO VOTE ON
THIS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. JONES
SAWYER HERE LACKEY. ME OF ANTI.
BRIAN STONE SANTIAGO SEYARTO-
BROWN'S PRESIDENT ALSO FOR THE
MEMBERS THAT JUST JOINED HIS
OFFICE CALENDAR DAY PULL BY THE
AUTHOR IS AB SIXTEEN OH THREE
SALAS DAPP SHOPLIFTING POOL
BUDDY AFTER ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
AB. ONE FIVE NINE SEVEN FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WALDRON SHOPLIFTING
INCREASED PENALTIES FOR PRIOR
CRIMES POLL BY THE OFFICE. AND
HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS WITH THE
CONFUSION ONLINE TO- OF BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN PULLED FOR
TODAY'S SECOND CALENDAR. MISTER
CHAIR AT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AGAIN FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE. SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MORNING MY NAME IS
JAMES FRAZIER- ON BOARD MEMBER
FOR A LOCAL CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY WE DO NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL
WE BELIEVE THAT- NO EVERY SECOND
RIGHT SPEAKS WITH THANK WE'RE IN
WE'RE IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. SO
OPPOSITION WILL COME SOON THIRD
RIGHT NOW THIS IS FOR SUPPORT.
LINE SIXTY EIGHT- I AM IN SUPPLY
I AM IN OPPOSITION. MY NAME ARMY
AND JUST A MOMENT PLEASE LINE
SIXTY FIVE. YEAH I'M IN
OPPOSITION OFFICE. OKAY JUST A
MOMENT YOU KNOW I AM AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE'RE
GONNA NOW GO TO LINE EIGHTY FOUR
. THIS IS JOHN HICKMAN I AM THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE NEVADA COUNTY
GUN OWNERS AND THE C. R. PA LIKE
MEMBER ALSO NRA LIFE MEMBER. I
AM IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SO
YOU KNOW WE MAY DO IF WE JUST
LET EVERYBODY COMMENT GET THIS
GET THIS GET THIS THAT SO
OPERATOR OPEN THE BLINDS FOR
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT LET'S GET
THIS THAT OTHERWISE WILL BE HERE
. FOR QUITE SOME TAKE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO LINE FIFTY TWO. BUT ME WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO.
AND I BELIEVE SOME PEOPLE MAY
HAVE REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM Q.
JUST A MOMENT.
LINE ONE OH FIVE. SORRY I AND I
AM IN OPPOSITION AS WELL I'M SO
SORRY THE CURE YOU MAY YOU MAY
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. OKAY I'M MANY
MACHINE A LARGE AND COMPLEX
ACCOUNTING AND I'M IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BELL. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NINE THIRTY FOUR. YEAH MY NAME
IS JULIE AND I'M LOW AND I'M AN
ORANGE COUNTY RESIDENTS- AND I
AM WITH WOMEN FOR AMERICAN
VALUES AND ETHICS AND WE SUPPORT
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WHY IN. TWENTY
SEVEN. MY TWENTY SEVEN YEAR ONE
IS OPEN. LINE. ONE OH SEVEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TRUE THEN LIEU
AND I'M CALLING FROM WAVE AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY. MY NAME IS ROSE AND
SHARP AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF
NEVER AGAIN CA WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT A. B. ONE SEVEN SIX NINE
THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY ONE. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER LONG BOMB AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY NINE AND WHAT NEVER AGAIN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. LINE.
NINETY FIVE. MY NAME IS MEGAN
MAYER I'M WITH DARK SKY
EXPLORING THAT PHONE IN
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I AM
CALLING YOU TRANSPORT IT AB ONE
SEVEN SIX NINE. LINE SIXTY TWO.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DARREN BEDLAM A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I'M CALLING IN IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. A LINE. THIRTY NINE.
HI MY NAME IS CARLENE ELLIS I'M
A COMPETITION SHOOTER I'M WITH
THE ARMED WOMEN OF AMERICA THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND THE GUN OWNERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A. B. CONTAINS
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. LINE TWENTY FOUR. MAKE YOUR
CARE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECORD DAN READ WESTERN
REGIONAL DIRECTOR WITH NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE
BECAUSE GUN OWNERS YOU
CALIFORNIA STRONG OPPOSITION AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY NINE. MY
NAME IS STEVE RODDA I'M WITH THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION U. S. NAVY VETERAN
REQUESTING THAT THE COMMITTEE
OPPOSE AB SIX SEVENTEEN SIXTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY NINE. PICTURE THIS
DEMOCRAT I'M THE CHAIR OF THE US
SOUTH SACRAMENTO **** OF CHAPTER
MINORITY MEMBER. AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE FIVE HUNDRED-
SIGNATURE OVER FIVE OR SIX IS
REFLECTED THE THIS THIS WEEKEND
IN SUPPORT OF KEEPING THE OF
INSURANCE- GUN SHOW- ARMENT
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR. NINE ONE OH SIX.
TONY RIOS AND I AM A MEMBER OF
WOMEN FOR AMERICAN VALUES AND
ETHICS I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. ONE SIX ONE SEVEN SIX NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
FIVE YEAH THIS IS TAMMY BONTA I
AM PART OF CENTER COUNTY GUN
OWNERS I AM ALSO AN L. A. COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO THIS IS MY FAIRGROUNDS I
HAVE ATTENDED WEEKS HERE FOUR
EIGHT I HAVE ATTENDED NUMEROUS
FORMER IRVINE FORTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING RECORD KERRY HOW CAN BUT
DOESN'T RATIONAL WORKMEN
FOUNDATION HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
OH NINE- MORNINGTERM MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PRINCE ACOSTA ON A
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. D. LINE FOURTEEN.
THIS IS NICK VELLA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE ON VERY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU
SIR. WHAT ONE CAN. IRISH SHARP
FROM NEVER AGAIN CA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE SEVEN SIX
NINE. THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
EIGHT PAUL KATZ A MEMBER OF
VENTURA COUNTY GUN OWNERS A
CITIZEN OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
FATHER OF THREE CHILDREN IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO HAVE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE MORE
PERSON SIGNALED THEY WISH TO
SPEAK WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
SEVENTY ONE. HI THIS IS CHOICE
WHAT WE'RE DOING MONTH FROM LAKE
PORT CALIFORNIA MEMBER C. R. PA.
I WANT YOU TO OPPOSE- WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. ONE SEVEN
SIX NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU. OF
BLIND ONE NO. EIGHT WHY ONE
AWAIT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PARDON
ME. LINE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING I'M CINDY CLEMONS WITH
NEVER AGAIN CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING THE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE SEVEN SIX NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERSACE'S
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
POLICY CHANGE. THANK YOU. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. BECAUSE
OF THE PLEDGE WE DIDN'T AFFORD
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WANTED TO SPEAK.
IN OPPOSITION SIDE DINNER
FEATURES ANYONE IN YOUR
AUDIENCE. I WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. GIVEN THEM FIVE
MINUTES SEEING NONE. OF WELL
NOW- BERTIE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WITH QUESTIONS. AT THE SERVICE
HERE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT FOR
YOUR BILL- THIS IS SPECIFIC TO
RIVERSIDE ARMENIA VENTURA COUNTY
CORRECT. SO WHY DID THE BOARDS
NOT JUST DO THIS THEMSELVES IF
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT MENTOR
COUNTY EMBRACES. GOOD QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE VENTURA
COUNTY FAIR BOARD JUST BEEN
VOTING FOUR TO THREE-
CONSISTENTLY ON THIS ISSUE AND
ONE OF THE REASONS CITED BY THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN WILLING
TO SUPPORT YET AS THEY FEEL LIKE
THE STATE- THIS SPRING A STATE
FAIRGROUNDS AT THE STATE SHOULD
BE TAKING THIS ACTION THEY'RE
GETTING ADVICE- THAT THIS SHOULD
BE DONE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
EXETER THAT THAT'S THE MORE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL TO DO THIS SO-
BUT BOTTOM LINE IS. AN ISSUE THE
PEOPLE ON- EVERYWHERE I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT ARE FAIR BOARD-
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THE MEANT
ANYWHERE NEAR THE MAJORITY VIEW
OF THE PEOPLE OF VENTURA COUNTY
I THINK THE MORE ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION OF WHERE THE
PEOPLE ARE IS THE FACT THAT THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF INTER
COUNTY VOTED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THE CITY COUNCIL OF VENTURE
OF WHERE THE FAIRGROUNDS IS
LOCATED OR VOTED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IN OXNARD- THE LARGEST
CITY IN VENTURA COUNTY ALL THREE
AND THEY'RE THE CLOSEST CITIES
TO THE FAIRGROUNDS SO THE
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN VERY CLEARLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THE FAIR
BOARD- UNFORTUNATELY DOESN'T I
THINK REFLECT THE VALUES OF THE
PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY AND- VENTURA
COUNTY AND PARTICULARLY ANYWHERE
NEAR THE FAIRGROUNDS THANK YOU
DO YOU. THINK MAYBE THAT'S BE.
BUSINESS TO. AND MAKING THEM
VIABLE OR DID THEY FEEL OTHER
PEOPLE PEOPLE INVENTOR WILL GO
TO NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY OUR
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES AND SHOP
THERE INSTEAD I THINK I'VE
LEARNED OVER THE YEARS THAT IT'S
REALLY DANGEROUS TO ATTRIBUTE
WHAT WHAT SOMEBODY ELSE'S
MOTIVES ARE FOR WHAT THEY DO
UNDERSTAND. FOR THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHER- QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
INTEREST FROM OF PEOPLE FROM ALL
AROUND THE STATE THAT HAVE-
CALLED IN ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE- BUT I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THIS IS A REQUEST OF
THE ELECTED OFFICIALS IN VENTURA
COUNTY- THIS IS A BILL THAT IS
NARROWLY TAILORED TO VENTURA
COUNTY THE VENTURA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS I CERTAINLY THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD THIS WAY. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADJOURNMENT
YOU'RE WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS I KNOW OTHER OF PARAGRAPHS
HAVE COME TO THIS THIS IS
COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY- TO DO
THE SAME DANCE- IT MUST BE
SOMETHING THAT MOST PEOPLE THINK
IS APPROPRIATE THAT THE STATE
TAKE CARE OF THEIR OWN STATE
FAIRGROUNDS AND SO I DID IS
TELLING APPROPRIATE FOR US. TO
MAKE DETERMINATION WITH THAT.
AND I VOTE. I NEED A SECOND. A
SECOND OVERALL ON EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTY NINE BY SUMMER BENNETT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I'D
LACKEY LACKEY NO BONTA. BONTA I
BRIAN BRIAN AYE STONE. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I SEYARTO SEYARTO NO.
THE BILL TRUMP TOLD ME TO ONE
MORE ABOUT THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK MR KILEY HE'S GONNA ALLOW
MR LEVINE **** BECOME FOR
BECAUSE HE HAD A HEART STOP-
BECAUSE THE TECHNICAL. TO KILEY
IT THE OTHER ONE WENT A LITTLE
LONGER. AS YOU PROBABLY HEARD WE
WERE. HOPEFULLY WE DON'T HAVE
THE SAME PROBLEM. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
AGAIN THANK YOU TO MR KILEY MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY FOUR WOULD EXTEND THE
SUNSET ON THE AUTHORITY USE
ACTUAL PERSPIRATION JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
WATCHING PERSPIRATION IS A TOOL
THAT CAN BE USED TO ADDRESS
VIOLATIONS OF AN OFFENDER AS
CONDITIONS OF PROBATION. OR
MANDATORY SUPERVISION BY
OPPOSING THE SHORT DETENTION OF
UP TO TEN DAYS AND CAN BE
EFFECTIVE IN DETERRING FUTURE
VIOLATIONS. THE SANCTIONS LIKE
FLASHING CARS IN BOUNCE THE NEED
TO HOLD OFFENDERS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR VIOLATIONS. OTHER
SUPERVISION WHILE FOCUSING ON
SHORTER DISRUPTIONS FROM WORK
HOME OR PROGRAMMING WITHOUT
FLASHING CARS RACING NORMAL
REVOCATION HEARINGS WOULD TAKE
PLACE RESULTING. IN LONG COURT
PROCEEDINGS AND UP TO ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IN CUSTODY.
THIS BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE SIMPLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU AND I WITH
ME AS A WITNESS IS DANIEL
SANCHEZ FROM THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA. YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEAP PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA- PLEASED TO SPONSOR
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR-
PROBATION UTILIZES GRADUATED
INTERVENTIONS- TO ADDRESS
VIOLATIONS OF A PERSON'S COURT
ORDERED- TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF
PROBATION THESE GRADUATED
INTERVENTIONS ARE INTENDED TO
BE- INCREMENTAL AND
PROPORTIONAL- AND REALLY
REFLECTS A LOT- THE SCIENCE AND
THE EVIDENCE. BASED RESEARCH ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF INTERVENING
WITH SWIFT AND CERTAIN RESPONSES
WHILE TRYING TO BE AS LESS
DISRUPTIVE AS POSSIBLE TO AN
INDIVIDUAL'S- REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING AND OTHER CONTINUITY
OF SERVICES- THAT THEY'RE
RECEIVING. CAN YOU TO USES
OPTION SHORT OF USING FLASH OR
FILING A PETITION OF REVOCATION
WHEN SAFE AND APPROPRIATE TO
ADDRESS COURT VIOLATIONS OF
PROBATION VERY MUCH RECOGNISES
THAT CHANGES A PROCESS AND WE
ARE INVESTED IN SEEING PEOPLE
SUCCEED AND DO WELL- HOWEVER
THERE ARE CERTAIN. INSTANCES AND
SIGNIFICANT VIOLATIONS THAT RISE
TO THE LEVEL OF BRINGING
SOMEBODY BACK BEFORE THE COURT.
AND USING A FLASH IS A GRADUATED
INTERVENTION IS A WAY TO
ADDRESS- THOSE SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS IN A BALANCED WAY
TOO AGAIN TRY TO KEEP CONTINUITY
FOR THEM- IN IN THEIR-
PROBATION. WITHOUT FLASHES AN
INTERMEDIATE RESPONSE THAT RISES
TO THE LEVEL OF BRINGING
SOMEBODY BACK BEFORE THE COURT.
AT THE EXISTING MECHANISM TO
ADDRESS THESE TYPES OF
VIOLATIONS IS TO INITIATE FORMAL
REVOCATION COURT PROCEEDINGS-
WHICH IS A MUCH LENGTHIER
PROCESS I CAN RESULT IN MUCH
LONGER PERIODS OF CUSTODY- I
WOULD JUST KNOW WE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMITTEE
COURTS AND MANY MANY
STAKEHOLDERS- OVER THE YEARS AND
DEVELOPING THIS. THERE IS
LANGUAGE THAT I MEAN THIS BILL.
THAT PROVIDES THE ABILITY FOR A
PERSON TO DECLINE FLASH INSTEAD
GO THROUGH THE COURT REVOCATION
PROCESS- AND SO IN CLOSING I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT- WE
CERTAINLY SEE THIS AS A BALANCED
APPROACH TO- HOLDING INDIVIDUALS
ACCOUNTABLE MAINTAINING SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS BUT AGAIN IN A
WAY THAT FOCUSES ON. SHORTER
DISRUPTIONS FROM WORK HOME
PROGRAMMING THAT CAN RESULT FROM
THOSE LONGER TERM REVOCATIONS-
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY OUR GOAL IS
TO. AT YOU KNOW ENSURE THE
SAFETY BUT TO DO SO IN A WAY
THAT WORKING- IN THE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING. AS A
WITHOUT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT ON AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
WITH THAT ROTEL TO THE FOUNDER
ANY WITNESSES ON THE FROM IN
SUPPORT. OKAY SO MANY AUDIENCE
THANK YOU MISTER POPULOUS TO THE
ROOM PAYING RENT AND SUPPORT IN
THE AUDIENCE. THIS IS NEW FOR ME
SO I HAVEN'T HAD AN AUDIENCE
AND- QUITE SOME TIME. HI THERE
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS MY
SO CALLED ME- ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER YOU ARE
WE READY FOR THE PHONE. NO GET
YOU HAVE TO MORE WITNESSES THAT
ARE IN THE ROOM AND THEY WILL GO
TO FUND. MORE MISTER MEMBERS
RANCHO NORTH RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT ALSO IN
SUPPORT SANTA ANA POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. AND POS
FROM RIVERSIDE NEWPORT BEACH
CORONA. POMONE ARCADIA CULVER
CITY FOR TEN AND BURBANK CALLING
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHARMERS COURCELLES
ALONG BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINETY MAY GO
TO THE FUND- PEOPLE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
FOUR OPERATED. BECAUSE CHAIR AND
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPECIFIC BELL.
WELL NOW GO TO LINE. ONE OH
FIVE. ONE OF FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SHARE REMEMBER. YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE. OKAY
SHOULD I WATCH WHAT BUDGET
COUNTY ANIMAL OR A ABC NEED TWO
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. I WAS SUPPORT OF- I'M
ENOUGH AND STRONG OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL- LINE. FIFTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MATTHEW SIDE REELING ON THE APP
THE LOS ANGELES PROBATION
OFFICERS UNION OUT THE LOCAL
SIXTY FIVE THE COURT AB SEVENTY
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THIRTY. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
CHAIRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF RIDE MORE MUNY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
HERE EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR A
BI SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU. TO ENSURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION VARINDER
HEARING ROOM RIGHT NOW. THEN
WILL GO TO THE FOUND- OPPOSITION
TO STE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR.
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP THE
LINES OPPOSITION. TO SEVENTEEN
FORTY FOUR. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FRONTIER PRESS
ONE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT. THE. AND
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. I KNOW ONE
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING SURE
COMMITTEE THIS IS GREGORY FELT
INITIATE JUSTICE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. CONCERNED COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSER TO
LIVING THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MMHM NEED A MOTION AND
SECOND. THE BILL THAT. FIVE
TWELVE AND IT WENT SO MUCH WAS
GOING ON. A CHAIRED FUHRMAN I
WROTE ONE RURAL. ON AB FORTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMBERS LEVINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
HI JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY
I BONTA OUR BONTA HI BRIAN.
ABSTAINED BRIAN ABSTAINING STONE
. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I SEYARTO
THEY ARE TAUGHT I. THE BILL
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THINKING MEMBERS
THANK YOU AND NOW FOR MISTER
KYLIAN THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. SO THAT'S KILEY AB.
ONE FIVE NINE NINE. I DON'T
NUMBER SIX THIS IS COMING IN SO
MMHM I HAVE A WITNESSES COMING
IN OKAY DID. BUT A CLOSE. OKAY
DO YOU WANT TO START YOUR
OPENING REMARKS ARE DELIVERED
FOR THEM. BUT THEY'RE HERE. IF
YOU WITNESSES YOU CAN THE STATE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE GIVES CALIFORNIA
VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO REPEAL
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN. PASSED
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN A PROP
FORTY SEVEN WAS THE BILL BE
SAFER NEIGHBOURHOOD AND SCHOOLS
ACT- THE INITIATIVE IT WAS
SUPPOSEDLY GOING TO LOWER
CALIFORNIA'S PRISON POPULATION
WILL ALLOW IN THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM FOCUS ON MORE SERIOUS
CRIMES BUT WHAT WE'VE NOW SEEN
SEVEN YEARS LATER IS THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE LESS SAFE THAN
EVER. PROP FORTY SEVEN- WHEN IT
WAS IT INTRODUCED WHEN HIS
PROPOSED WAS NEARLY UNIVERSALLY
OPPOSED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE REASONS BECAME CLEAR SOON
AFTER ITS PASSAGE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE YEAR AFTER- PROP
FORTY SEVEN PASSED THE LA TIMES
REPORTED THAT QUOTE LAW.
OFFICIALS AND OTHERS HAVE AIMS
PROP FORTY SEVEN FOR ALLOWING
REPEAT OFFENDERS TO CONTINUE
BREAKING THE LAW WITH LITTLE
CONSEQUENCE. A SEPARATE PIECE IN
THE TIMES FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN
REPORTED THAT IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES PROPERTY CRIMES SUCH AS
BURGLARIES AND MOTOR VEHICLE
THEFTS HAVE RISEN TEN POINT 9%
COMPARED WITH THE SAME PERIOD
LAST YEAR VIOLENT CRIMES SUCH AS
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS AND
ROBBERIES HAS SOARED TWENTY
POINT SIX PERCENT. OUR STUDY WHO
IS MARITIME I TOLD THE TIMES
THAT THOSE INCREASES MAY BE
LINKED TO PROP FORTY SEVEN. IN
MAY OF TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS REPORTED LARGE
RETAILERS INCLUDING SAFE WAY
TARGET RITE AID AND CVS
PHARMACIES SAY SHOPLIFTING
INCREASED AT LEAST 15% AND IN
SOME CASES DOUBLED SINCE VOTERS
APPROVED PROP FORTY SEVEN. A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STUDY FROM THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA FOUND THE PROP FORTY
SEVEN LED TO A SPIKE IN CASES OF
LARCENY AND MOTOR VEHICLE THEFT.
DESCRIBING THAT STUDY THE LA
TIMES REPORTED THAT CALIFORNIA
VOTERS DECISION TO REDUCE
PENALTIES FOR DRUG AND PROPERTY
CRIMES IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
CONTRIBUTED TO A JUMP IN CAR
BURGLARIES SHOPLIFTING AND OTHER
THEFT LARCENIES JUMPED IN
CALIFORNIA AS THEY DECLINED
ELSEWHERE. WE ALSO SAW A MARKET
DECLINE PARTICIPATION IN A DRUG
ARTS DRUG TREATMENT- OWING TO
THE LACK OF LEVERAGE THE
PROSECUTORS NOW HAD I TO
ENCOURAGE OFFENDERS TO SIGN UP
FOR TREATMENT. OVER TIME THE
SITUATION HAS CONTINUED TO
WORSEN IT IS REACHED A BREAKING
POINT IN RECENT MONTHS LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO AND OTHER
MAJOR CITIES HAVE RECENTLY BEEN
STRICKEN BY LARGE SCALE
ORGANIZED RETAIL STOPS RESULTING
IN NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF MERCHANDISE BEING
STOLEN. A SPOKESPERSON FOR
TARGET ANY TO SAID IN A
STATEMENT FOR THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING A
SIGNIFICANT AND ALARMING RISE IN
THEFT AND SECURITY INCIDENTS. AT
OUR SAN FRANCISCO STORES SIMILAR
TO REPORTS FROM OTHER RETAILERS
IN THE AREA. IN THE LAST YEAR
TRAIN COMPANY OFFICIALS AT UNION
PACIFIC RELEASED DATA SHOWING A
ONE HUNDRED AND 60% YEAR OVER
YEAR INCREASE IN THEFT ALL THEIR
LINES BLAMING THE SPIKE ON
CHANGES TO HOW LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES ARE PROSECUTED. TAKING
IN THE SCENE GAVIN NEWSOM SAID
THAT IT LOOKED LIKE A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY. ALL THE ALL PART
OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT.
RETAILERS ARE OFTEN I AT THIS
POINT I JUST AVOID
CONFRONTATIONS WITH SHOPLIFTERS
OR DON'T EVEN FILE POLICE
REPORTS- BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT-
NOTHING IS LIKELY TO HAPPEN IF
THEY DO. SO THIS CREATED THIS IS
CREATED A TOTAL BREAKDOWN IN THE
RULE OF LAW SYSTEM WAR CRIMINALS
FEEL WHOLLY FREE TO ACT OUTSIDE
OF THE LAW WITHOUT FEAR. OF
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES WE'VE ALL
SEEN VIDEOS OF WHAT HAPPENS-
THERE WAS ONE THAT WENT VIRAL
RECENTLY WHERE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO WALGREENS A MAN
CASUALLY LOADS HIS BICYCLE I
WITH THE BAG FULL OF STOLEN
GOODS. AND IS BARELY EVEN OUT
HAPA BOTHERED AS HE AS HE RIDES
OUT AS HE WALKS OUT THE DOOR. IT
IS SIMPLY NOT FAIR TO LAW
ABIDING CALIFORNIANS WHO DESERVE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SAFE SAFE
TO LIVE IN SAFETY. AGAIN BEEN
STATE. KIDS OPEN AND IT'S ALL
NOT FAIR TO THE- THEMSELVES WHO
ARE DEPRIVED OF THE TREATMENT
AND REHABILITATION NEEDED. TO
TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND. IF WE
ARE GOING TO DO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM. IT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN A
SMART STRATEGIC. EVIDENCE BASED
WAY. PROP FORTY SEVEN WAS THE
OPPOSITE A BLIND AND SWEEPING
DECRIMINALIZATION. WHICH TOOK A
HATCHET TO OUR PENAL CODE AND
IMPERILLED OUR CITIZENRY.
CALIFORNIANS ARE UNWILLING TO
TOLERATE THIS ANY LONGER.
ACCORDING TO A POLL BY UC
BERKELEY'S INSTITUTE OF
GOVERNMENTAL STUDIES 78% OF
RESPONDENTS FEEL THAT CRIME IS
INCREASING IN CALIFORNIA. AND BY
A TWO TO ONE MARGIN. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS FAVOR CHANGES TO PROP
FORTY SEVEN. EVEN ATTORNEY
GENERAL ART ROB BONTA SAID THAT
SOME FOLKS ARE WONDERING IF
THERE IS CAUSATION BETWEEN THESE
PROPOSITIONS REFERRING TO 47-57
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING TODAY AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL DECIDED THAT
YES THERE MAY BE. HE SAID HE
BACKS CHANGES TO ADDRESS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
CONSEQUENCES AND TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE. NOW I SERVED WITH MR BONTA
FOR SEVERAL YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE ARE NOT EXACTLY
IN LOCKSTEP ON ISSUES OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE ARE
PRETTY MUCH DIAMETRICALLY
OPPOSED DIFFERENT VOTING RECORDS
BUT AT THE POINT AT WHICH BOTH
OF US ARE SAYING THERE NEEDS TO
BE CHANGES- I THINK THAT IS A
VERY GOOD REASON. FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO ADVANCE THIS BILL
TODAY AND IN FACT BY VOTING IN
FAVOR OF THIS MEASURE YOU'RE NOT
EVEN SAYING THAT YOU WANT TO
NECESSARILY I'LL GET RID OF PROP
FORTY SEVEN ALL YOU'RE SAYING IS
THAT YOU WANT TO LET THE VOTERS
DECIDE. THAT IS WHAT THIS
MEASURE DOES AS GEORGE SKELTON
WROTE IN THE LA TIMES PROP FORTY
SEVEN SHOULD B RETURNED TO THE
VOTERS AND EXCHANGE FOR A
PRODUCT THAT WORKS BETTER FOR US
ONE. MY FIRST WITNESS SIDE TO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE DIVERT
YOUR SON WHO IS THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- ELDORADO COUNTY IN THE
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT. OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
ONE DIDN'T USED TO BE IRISH
TIMES THE- OKAY WE CAN ABOUT
THAT OKAY THANK. CHAIR IN THANK
YOU S. MEMBER- KILEY AND THANK
YOU TO THEM ALL OF THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. FOR
PERMITTING US TO BE HERE AS
INDICATED I'M MY NAME IS VERN
PIERSON AND IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF CDA. I'M HERE TODAY
BOTH AS THEY'LL DORADO COUNTY D.
A. AS WELL AS ON BEHLF OF. THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. ENCOURAGING YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I WILL
WILL ECHO JUST A FEW THINGS
THAT- SIMILAR KILEY ALLUDED TO.
BUT MOST SIGNIFICANTLY IS A
RECOGNITION OF OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM
HERE AND- HOWEVER WELL
INTENTIONED PROP FORTY SEVEN. A
WELL INTENTIONED. SUPPORTED IT-
OVER TIME WHAT WE HAVE SEEN. IS
THAT IT HAD HAS HAD NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES. THAT WE'RE ASKING
YOU TO GIVE THE VOTERS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVISIT- MOST
NOTABLY THAT I WANT TO DRESS
TODAY. IS THAT- PROP FORTY SEVEN
ESSENTIALLY KILLED THE DRUG
COURTS IN CALIFORNIA. BY
ELIMINATING ANY CONSEQUENCE- IN
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THE
JUDGES THAT HAVE WERE CONDUCTING
EFFECTIVE DRUG COURTS- AND
LEADING TO EFFECTIVE
REHABILITATION. ALL OF THEM ARE
UNANIMOUS IN SAYING IF YOU TALK
TO THEM OBVIOUSLY JUDGES ARE NOT
LOBBYING BUT- TALK ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES PROP FORTY SEVEN K.
RECORDS. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
YIELD BACK TO REBEL TO THE TIME
TO THE. OTHERS- YES. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN UNDERSTAND DICUS
IN THE SHERPAS ALBERTINO I
REPRESENT TWO POINT TWO MILLION
RESIDENTS I ALSO REPRESENT TEN
MUNICIPAL POLICE CHIEF FOURTEEN
CONTRACTS CITIES AND THE LAWN
JUSTICE GROUP IN SAN MARINO
COUNTY. SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
WE'VE EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
STATE REALIGNMENT INITIATIVES
THAT HAVE PUSHED TRADITIONALLY
STATE RESPONSIBILITIES DOWN TO
YOUR LOCAL COUNTIES AND CITIES
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT PROP
FORTY SEVEN IS JUST ONE OF THESE
THINGS. AS WE WRANGLE WITH THIS
CONVERSATION I'M GONNA COME INTO
LOCKSTEP IN AGREEMENT WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN A RECENT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU WE SAID
THIS WASN'T AN PROP FORTY SEVEN
PROBLEM WELL I BEG TO DIFFER IT
IS A PROP FORTY SEVEN PROBLEM.
WHERE I AM IN LOCKSTEP WITH YOU
IS THAT ANYTIME YOU TALK ABOUT
ANY OF THESE INITIATIVES YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT CAPACITY AND
MOSTLY LACK THERE OF. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN ALL OF THESE
INITIATIVES TO PUT THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE AND FORCE YOUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO TRY TO
BUILD THESE CAPACITIES THAT DO
NOT EXIST. I WOULD EXPRESS TO
YOU THAT YOU WOULD SUPPORT
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE SO THAT IT
CAN GO BACK TO THE VOTERS AND
HEAR WHAT YOUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE
TO SAY AS A RELEASE AS IT
RELATES TO CRIME. AND THE NUMBER
OF CAPACITIES EXIST THIS IS
BRITTANY FOR ALL OF US TO
PARTNER ACROSS THE AISLE FROM
EACH OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
NOT. BLUE LAUNCHED ABOUT DOING
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR OUR CITIZENS IF
WE MEET TOGETHER WE BUILD THESE
CAPACITIES WILL BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING FOR THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. IN TERMS OF DATA.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET A LOT OF
DATA FROM YOUR BUSINESS IS OUT
THERE BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T
REPORT PETTY THEFT ANYMORE
BECAUSE THERE'S NO. POINTS IS
FOR THAT CRIME. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
FORD IN SAN MARINO COUNTY TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE JAIL
UTILIZATION STUDY. IN THAT
STUDY. BASED ON PRISON
REALIGNMENT WE HOLD PEOPLE THAT
SOCIETY ARE TRULY AFRAID OF. THE
ONES THAT WE CAN AFFECT THE MOST
TWO DIFFERENT REFORMS. ARE THE
FOLKS THAT ARE NOT SPENDING
ENOUGH TIME IN JAIL THIS IS WHAT
THE STUDY PROVED FORWARD NOT
EVEN THIRTY DAYS SO NO G. E. D.
NO SUBSTANCE ABUSE TRAINING THEY
GET STARTED AND THEY DON'T
FINISH WHILE THEY'RE IN CUSTODY
WITH US. THE LACK OF DRUG COURT
WE HAVE A HUMAN CONDITION THAT'S
EXPRESSED IN OUR STREETS RIGHT
NOW OUR PEOPLE ARE RIDING IN
THEIR OWN SKIN BECAUSE THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO INTERVENTION. AS
IT RELATES TO THIS. AND THE
LIFE'S BLOOD. OF THIS STATE IS
OUR BUSINESSES WHO ARE LEAVING
BECAUSE WE CANNOT PROTECT THEM
AND THEY'RE BECOMING VICTIMIZED.
AND LOSING MONEY WHICH ALSO
RESULTS OBVIOUSLY AND TAXES AND
OUR ABILITY IS PUBLIC SAFETY TO
SUPPORT HIM. I WOULD URGE ALL OF
YOU TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. GET BACK TO
THE VOTERS HERE WHAT THEY HAVE
TO SAY UNLESS MAKE CALIFORNIA
SAFE. AND BRING. CONGRESSIONAL
SEATS BACK TO THE STATE AND SHOW
THAT THE CALIFORNIA DREAM IS
ALIVE AND WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND I WILL BRING TO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THAT FOR
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN THE ROOM NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE GERMAN
SORRY THANK YOU. RESPECTED BY
SHERIFF CHAD BIANCO RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE THIRTEEN MUNICIPAL
CHIEF TYPICAL CHIEFS OF POLICE
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AND THE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. YOU. GOOD MORNING
JEFF HI MY NAME IS DEAR AND
GOODMAN FROM THE UPLAND POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND ALSO REPRESENT
THE SALMON AND YOU KNOW COUNTY
CHIEFS AND SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SIR. RIGHT I GOT
ONE- ROSEVILLE AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REPRESENTING OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED BUSINESSES AND
PLASTER COUNTY ANDTHEIR TALENTS
OF EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SOIL THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING I'M
PATRICK VEGAS WITH THE WESTFIELD
GALLERIA AT ROSEVILLE WE WERE A
RECENT VICTIM OFFICE ACTION
GRABBED WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DAY BUTLER
IN BEHALF OF THE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK A COALITION OF
SEVEN. LOCAL CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYERS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS HERE
SINCE DAY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN COUNCIL PUBLIC
POLICY FAITH BASED INSTITUTE- WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT AB FIFTY
NINE. THANK YOU SIR- MY NAME'S
GREG BIRD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR. RENDON CAMPBELL
PASTOR THE FAITH BAPTIST CHURCH
IN WHEELING CALIFORNIA AND
DIRECTOR OF THE BAPTIST PASTORS
PASTORS CAPITAL CONNECTION AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR. ALL POLL. MORNING BRANCHEN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT
OF FIFTEEN NINETY NINE ON BEHALF
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATIONS OF
SANTA ANA RIVERSIDE NEWPORT
BEACH CORONA CLAREMONT PALACE
VERDES UPLAND ANGLE WOULD POMONA
ARCADIA CULVER CITY FULLERTON
BURBANK AND ALSO THE PLASTER
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MR CHARMERS
COURSE ALSO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE DECADE-
OPERATOR WITHOUT VOTED LINE FOR
A- WORDS SUPPORT. AB FIFTY S. AV
OF FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF
YOU WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT FOR
NOW GO TO LINE ONE OH FIVE. I
DON'T KNOW FIVE. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES- GOOD ACTORS ARE GOOD
MORNING TURNED HER MEMBERS I'M
IN STRONG MANY DISLODGED THE
BALL FROM BERKSHIRE COUNTY. AND
I ALSO REPRESENT JAMES Q.
BRIBERY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN NINETY NINE.
WINE ONE FORTY. BIANCA FEDERALLY
BROADLANDS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE. PARDON ME
GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
SIX. ONE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN. YES MY
NAME IS KEVIN ROBERTS CAL
MELISSA. IN THE MICHIGAN. ONE OF
OPPOSITION THE FIFTEEN NINETY
NINE ON BEHALF OF THE AND YOU
SAID COALITION THANKS LINE. ONE
FIFTY. HI I'M REPRESENTS EVERY.
WHO IS TIED OF LIVING PARDON MY
IN THIS WHICH HOLE THANK YOU
LINE. FIFTIES. BACK TO BACK
CASEY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALLED
. IN RESPONSE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THAT A. B. ONE FIVE
NINE NINE THANK YOU LINE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS.
HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MAKAYLA AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION. TO ONE FIVE NINE NINE. THIS IS
IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR PICTURE
THIS IS A SUPPORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ONLY ASKING
PEOPLE TO SIGNAL THAT IF THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO. IN A GO
TO LINE SIXTEEN. PARDON ME JUST
A MOMENT NUMBER RENDON UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SUPPORT.
LINE ONE SIXTY. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBER KILEY SHALL BE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
CURRICULA AB FIFTEEN NINETY NIE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIXTY THREE
. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE SOVIET SO LISA SHAW CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTY OF
BUTTE AND ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
COUNTY A FACTOR BOTH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
. THE MORNING CARE ENCUMBERED AT
LEAST OURCITY ACCOUNT- WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT.
ABOUT BOND PROP FORTY SEVEN
WHETHER CHINA AYE MADE A CALL WE
ARE SITUATED. NINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE. BY ONE SEVENTY NINE. GOING
TO MOVE ON TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS CLINTON
DRUMMER I'M A LIFE COACH FOR THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE BLIND.
ONE EIGHTY NINE. MY NAME IS JOHN
ONE MAN BUT I WORK AND TIME
STUDENT COALITION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED. YES THANK YOU LINE BUT. NINETY TWO. BY ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER ACOSTA.
M. STAFF AT ANYTIME SOON QUOTE
COALITION AND I AM CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. TO FIFTEEN.
LINE. ONE NINETY SEVEN. HELLO
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S DEVON
ROAD FROM AN EMPLOYEE PREVENTIVA
COALITION NUMBER I'M CALLING
INTO A STRONGLY OPPOSE FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE THANK YOU OPERATOR
UNITED JUST LET. US GET IT ALL
DONE AT ONE TIME ON THE PHONE
AND THEY WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
AND- YES MISTER CHAIR. ONE ONE
SIXTY FIVE. YES HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE SAY WELL AND I OPPOSE
FORTY SEVEN I WANTED TO BE
REPEALED THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE. MY NAME IS
SHOPPERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC MAYBE THANK BY THE NEED
TO SPEAK. JIM BURNS. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. I FIVE. IT THANK
YOU ALL FOR ARE YOU THERE YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. WHY NOT. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. BY ONE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS
RIGHT SAID IN PARLIAMENT AND
CRACKED IF I GRADUATION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIFTY NINETY
NINE THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY ONE
FORTY SIX- BUT- LINE. ONE FORTY
NINE. I THINK THE CHALLENGE
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CALLS AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
AB FIFTEEN NINETY. THANK YOU
LINE. JUST A MOMENT. BY. TWO OH
SEVEN. ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL BUT
DEFINITELY I'M A LOT OF CALLS
FOR THE A. R. C. AND I'M CALLING
THIS DON'T OPPOSITION A. D.
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE THANK YOU.
HOME LINE TWO OH EIGHT. MY NAME
IS ROBERT DECAMP I AM A LIFE
COACH WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE THANK YOU.
BLIND TWO OH NINE. HELLO HELLO
LINE TWO OR NINE OR ONE IS OPEN
EVEN ORGANIZATION PATHFINDER
ANTHONY ROMERO I AM A LIFE COACH
AT ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED THE EIGHT
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. THANK YOU.
BLIND TO SIXTEEN. WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL FIRED A SUPERMAJORITY
POLITICIAN FOR PRESENT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE NOTS THANK YOU. FINE ONE SEVENTY THREE. MY
NAME TO CONNIE SHAW I AM WITH
TIME DONE IN ALSO SECRETARY OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY
ADVISORY BOARD AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AS A BE
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SIXTY ONE. HELLO MY
NAME IS ACTUALLY WINTRICH OF
WORK AND I THINK AT THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE FO PROJECT
MORNING CHAIRED THE MEMBERS AS
THE RECIPIENT OF THAT WE GOT
MARRIED REPUBLIC OPPOSED THAT SB
FIFTY NINE NINE. LINE TWO OH TWO
. MY NAME IS CANDACE LEWIS AND
I'M A LIFE COACH AND ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I AM
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU. WHY ONE THIRTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY MY NAME
IS AB ONE EDWARD THEM APOLOGY
JEFF IT WAS STARTING OVER
ENGINEER IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR. THE NEW. LINE.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ERIN YOUR V. ON BEHALF
OF PEOPLE CALIFORNIA GRASSROOTS
FAITH BASED ME ORGANIZING I WORK
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO FIFTEEN NINETY
NINE THANK YOU. YOU WHY I'M
CALLING YOU CAN ALSO. MY NAME IS
MARK K. LETTER AND I'M A LOT
CLOSER TO ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I AM CALLING AND
STRONG OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. THANK
YOU. LIE IN. NINETEEN ONE TO
NINETEEN OH ONE THE SUBURBS. I'M
CAUGHT MY NAME IS MICHAEL DORADO
ON POLY MEDIUM- QUIZSTAR OVER A
COMES STRONGLY OPPOSING A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE IF YOU. LINE. TWENTY THREE. MY TWENTY THREE
YEAR ONE IS NOW OPEN. LINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE AND. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS SEAN I'M A PAST
ACCOMPLISH OUT OF FOUR AM
CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
ONE FIVE NINE THAT COULD. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY NINE. HI MY
NAME IS JANE AND GERRY I'M
CALLING FROM LA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S CHEST STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB ONE NINE NINE THREE
ONE FIVE NINE NINE RIGHT. LINE.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE. MORNING MY
NAME IS GILBERT JOHNSON WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE TIME DONE REPRESENTING
THE MEMBERSHIP OF FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTEEN NINETY
NINE. LINE TO PATENT. YES MY
NAME IS ON COMPLEMENT YOUR ARM
AND THE DAYTON ART GRANT
COMPLICATED BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
A THE LIFE COACH ARMSTRONG
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE. LYING. TO THIRTY
TWO. HI MY NAME IS- DAVID AMAYA
I WORK FOR ANTIS RECIDIVISM
COALITION I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION MAY BE FIFTEEN NINETY
NINE. LINE ONE OH FIVE. IN ONE
OF FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN- HI
ALL RIGHT- YEAH I'M CALLING
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT'S REALLY
TERRIBLE THAT YOU GUYS ARE
CUTTING. LINE. ONE TWENTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS THIS
IS GREGORY FIDELITY ISSUE
JUSTICE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. WHY NOT ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. TOMORROW KEVIN LAMBERT MY
NAME IS LORALAI YEAH THE LOS
ANGELES I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN NINETY
NINE. LINE. ONE HELLO THIS IS
DANIEL WISELY IF YOU. YOU'RE NOT
GOING WE- PUBLISHING EIGHTEEN
NINE THAT. LINE. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. MY IDEA ASSEMBLY LED THE
AND YET PILLARS OF THE CAN AND
DYED I STAND WITH THE TEN
MILLION PEOPLE NO TO PROP TWENTY
AND WE STRONGLY THE BILL. LINE
ONE FORTY ONE. THE MORNING AND
MY NAME IS MY RODRIGUEZ I HAVE
BEEN LONG BEACH AND I AM CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. LINE ONE
FORTY TWO. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. LINE ONE
FORTY SIX. THE MORNING CARE
NUMBERS MANY DISTINGUISHED THE
OPEN I'M A LIFE COACH AT THE END
TIME UTILITIES AND COALITION AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. THANK
YOU. WHY NO. ONE SEVENTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HALEY AND I'M CALLING TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
NINETY THREE. J. LOCAL THE
OPERATOR LIVE IN CONCERT I
ALWAYS TRYING AND LOCATE. ONE
FIVE NINE NINE THANK YOU. LINE.
TO TWENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS STEVEN GREEN I'M A
MEMBER OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I AM AYE OPPOSED
AB FIFTY NINE NINE. THANK YOU.
WHY ARE YOU FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WILL MATTHEWS WITH UNITED
CHURCH OF CHRIST IN CALIFORNIA
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AT TO ROUTE
FIFTY NINE NOT. LINE. FIFTY ONE.
AT FIVE THIRTY ONE OR ONE IS NOW
OPEN. IN A MOVE ON TO LINE
SEVENTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS
KATHERINE O'CONNELL I AM CALLING
AND OF STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY TWO. PARDON ME WHY NEEDED
NOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS TOMMY DILEMMA I'M WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I
AM IN OPPOSITION. MAYBE. IN JUNE
PAUL DOT COM. I'VE BEEN
CAREGIVER FISHING IS LINE. FOUR
YOUR LIFE JUST GOT ALONG BOND
THE MURDER CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HI THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND FOR THE WHOLE BODY
TO LISTEN TO THE CALIFORNIA
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
YOU BINDING TO. WHILE THANK.
PARDON ME MR PARDON ME BUT
THERE'S A COUPLE WITH YOUR OPEN
PLEASE MEET YOUR PHONE LINE
PLACE A WITNESS A CO HOST YOU
HAVE YOUR MIND OPEN PLEASE YOU
SHOULD BE A BUTTON THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO LINE TWO FIFTY
SIX. WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON
TO LINE TO THIRTY SEVEN. THE
MORNING CARE AND STUFF MY NAME
AS ELIANA HONEY CUTS AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO-
EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY NINE ON
BEHALF OF THAT THE LOTUS WHAT
THE FOUNDATION THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FIFTY. YOUR GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DEREK IS AUDIBLE CRUNCH
SURVIVOR LOST TWO BROTHERS ARE
DEEPLY TROUBLED RECOVERY CENTERS
OF POT HOLES AB. WHAT PART NINE.
LINE. TWO OH FOUR. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JOHN HAUSER I'M WITH
TIME DONE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE I WAS
PERSONALLY IMPACTED AND HAVE
GONE ON TO BENEFIT TREMENDOUSLY
FROM THE OPPORTUNITY TO TURN MY
LIFE COMPLETELY AROUND OKAY GOT
IT SHOULD GET THE CHANCE TO.
THANK YOU. BLIND TO. MY NAME IS
DARBY ARAMBULA COACH THE ENTIRE
CALLED I'M CALLING THE OPPOSING
FIFTY MILLION ON. APPLYING. TO
THREE. FIND THREE OH ONE NOW-
BUT. NUMBER BONTA LINE. ONE
THIRTY ONE. BOTH PRIME CARRIAGE
MY NAME IS TERRA STORK AND I'M
WITH THE TIME DURING MOVEMENT
AND ATTACKS PAYER IT WOULD BE
EVERY TAXPAYER STRONGLY OPPOSED
- OKAY NEED BARS NOT. LINE. TO
THIRTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS BILLY
TANG I'M FROM THE ANTI COALITION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
LINE. SIXTY THREE. LINDA WATER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE THANK YOU.
BLIND. TWO SIXTY FOUR. YES MY
NAME IS STEVEN WENT OUT THERE
I'M A LOT COACH ABOUT HOW THIS
IS A COLLISION I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL ONE FIVE NINE NINE.
LINE. TWO SIXTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TO GET THE
EXACT- BATTLES I'M A LIFE COACH
AT THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY NINETY NINE. LINE TWO
SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
NUMBER BONTA LINE TO SIXTY ONE.
HI NOT THANK YOU SIXTY ONE YEAR
WONDERS OPEN. I HAVE A QUESTION
SO YOU'RE SAYING EVEN
ORGANIZATION GONNA GO TO. BLIND
TO SEVENTY FIVE. YEAH HI MY
NAME'S OPTED OUT TOO BUT- WAS
STARTING OVER EACH AND I AM
CALLING STRONG OPPOSITION AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. LINE TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN. DANIEL GOOD CARE
THEN THE CAPITA CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN OPPOSITION. LINE TWO SIXTY
WISE. THAT'S ONE TO SIXTY ONE NO
ONE IS NOW OPEN. THE MOBILE. TO
ONE TO THREE. YES MY NAME IS
TOMMY LAURA PALMER'S ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I AM A
STRONG OPPOSITION A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE. LINE. TWO FORTY
SIX. HI MY NAME IS JAMES AND I
THE MANAGER OF CONCRETE ADVOCATE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION ON
BEHALF OF OUR ORGANIZATION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. LINE. TWO EIGHTY ONE. THIS
IS OSTROBOTHNIA OF LIFE CLOSER
AFTERWARDS OF RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
ASSEMBLY BILL. FIFTY NINE NINE.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE MORE
PERSON TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. JUST A MOMENT. LINE.
TWO SEVENTY TWO. HI MY NAME IS
ADRIANA MARKET ARM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ALL OF
US ARE NOT FINISHED WRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB GIVES YOU NOT
NOT. LINE TWO SIXTY ONE. TWO
SIXTY ONE YEAR ONE IS NOW OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE COULD LOSE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK BACK THANK YOU AN
HOUR HERE- FROM FROM OPPOSITION
AND IF- THE TWO WHICH IS IN THE
SUPPORT COULD YOU PLEASE WINTER
CHAIR TODAY TO BE HONEST. AND IF
WE NEED TO BE FOR CLASS PLEASE
BE CLOSE. AND I HAVE TOM
HOFFMAN'S THE- CALIFORNIA STATE
DIGESTIVE AND ST LOUIS AT THE
RECIDIVISM COALITION. BOTH
TESTIFYING IN PERSON. SAME RULES
YOU HAVE A FIVE MINUTES TOTAL
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO SPLIT UP
. THANK YOU. TOM OFTEN I'M THE
BECAUSE SENIOR PUBLIC SAFETY
ADVISER FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. IN A
PREVIOUS LIFE I SPENT THIRTY ONE
YEARS IN MUNICIPAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY
YEARS LIVING WITH PD OFFICER TO
CAPTAIN ELEVEN YEARS WITH WAS
SACRAMENTO DO A DIP THE CHIEF.
CAPTAIN THE DEPUTY CHIEF OF OUR
RETIRED FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT I
WAS SUBSEQUENTLY APPOINTED THE
HEAD OF STATE PAROLE BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER AND I WASN'T SIX.
AGAIN UP APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT-
SERVE IN THAT CAPACITY FOR ABOUT
THREE AND A HALF YEARS. OF WE'RE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO OF
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE. OF THE IF
WE LOOK AT THE CENTRAL PREMISE
OF THE OF THIS BILL. SUGGESTING
THAT- PROP FORTY SEVEN
DECRIMINALIZE THESE OFFENSES AND
BASICALLY DOG BECAUSE DOOR TO
APPROVAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO BE
NEUTERED. THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
TRUE. ALL THESE CRIMES ARE STILL
MISDEMEANORS THEY CAN BE
PROSECUTED. THE DECISION NOT TO
PROSECUTE IS JUST THAT A
DISCRETIONARY DECISION NOT TO
SPEAKERS OF THE WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND OUR TIRE SYSTEM IS
OVERLOADED. BUT THEY CAN BE
BROUGHT TO TRIAL THEY CAN'T BE
CONVICTED THEY CAN BE SENTENCED
TO A COUNTY JAIL THEY CAN BE
ORDERED INTO TREATMENT IS A
DECISION NOT TO DO THAT.
SECONDARILY IT'S LOG ON THE
PREMISE THAT IN THIS NOT TO BE.
BUT CHIEF WE FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
ARREST PEOPLE IN PUT THEM IN BY
THIS IS AS FAR. WELL WE ALL BE
JUST FINE. THAT COLLIDES WITH
HISTORIC FACTS AND THAT FACT IS
THAT IN THIS IS A BIT PAINFUL.
TO TO ADMIT AS A CAREER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER AFTER THE
FACT VERY FEW PEOPLE ARE
CAPTURED AND IDENTIFIED AND
BROUGHT TO TRIAL VERY FEW. THE
JUNGLE CURRENT DOJ STATS FOR
CASE CLEARANCE OF THE CRIMES
LISTED IN IMPROV FORTY SEVEN
THIS YEAR OR LAST YEAR'S USE ME
EIGHT POINT FIVE PERCENT. THAT
DOES REPORTED CRIMES HALF OF
THESE CRIMES ARE NEVER REPORTED
WHICH IS A PROBLEM WE OUGHT TO
BE TALKING ABOUT. SAN FRANCISCO
PD IS AN EXAMPLE WHICH IS ONE OF
THOSE PLACES WE'VE ALL ABOUT FOR THE FORTY FIVE
YEARS I'VE BEEN IN THIS
BUSINESS. TWO PEOPLE ARE THREE
POINT SIX SEVEN CLEARANCE RATE.
SO IN ESSENCE WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO CONVINCE PEOPLE IS THAT AN
OUTCOME THERE'S A CHEAT LESS
THAN 5% OF THE TIME LESS THAN
THAT IS SOMEHOW THE CORNERSTONE
PIECE OF. LEGISLATION TO ENSURE
THE ABILITY TO ACHIEVE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THEN TO MAINTAIN IT.
AND THEN ALSO SAYS THAT IF WE
CAN'T DO THAT THEN THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S ALSO NOT
TRUE. THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE SYSTEM IF IT'S GOING TO BE
EXERCISED. ROAD TO THE FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLAR THRESHOLD. WELL
I'M THINKING WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT EVERY STATE IN THE UNION
HAS A THRESHOLD THAT TRIGGERS
THE MOVEMENT BETWEEN MISDEMEANOR
FELONY. CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS
A THRESHOLD THAT EXCEEDS THE
THRESHOLD IN THIRTY NINE OTHER
STATES. IT BROILED RELATIVE TO
THE FUNDING WHY WOULD WE NOT
WANT. IN THIS COMING YEAR A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO GO BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE SERVICES
AND RESOURCES INCLUDING VICTIM
HELP. THAT'S GENERATED UNIQUELY
BY PROP FORTY SEVEN AND UNIQUELY
TARGETED TOWARDS THOSE- THOSE
SORT. OF THOSE RESOURCES AND HAS
BEEN VERIFIED BY THE- BORDER
STATE COMMIT A COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS THAT WORK IT REDUCES
RECIDIVISM WHY WE TURN AROUND
SAY WE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT
ANYMORE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DIGNIFY THAT MONEY. WHAT'S THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT I TELL. YOU
MINUTES LEFT ARE YOU OKAY TO
QUICKLY. BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. WHAT IS THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT TO TELLING PEOPLE THEY
CAN NO LONGER CHANGE THEIR OR
THE RECORD FROM A FELONY TO A
MISDEMEANOR. WHY WOULD WE DO
THAT DO WE NOT UNDERSTAND THAT A
FELONY CONVICTION IS A IT PUTS A
BALL AND CHAIN AROUND PEOPLE'S
FEET THAT IS JUST INCREDIBLE BY
SOME COUNTS FOUR THOUSAND
LEGISLATIVELY IMPOSE YOU CAN'T
LOSE AS A FELON. WHY WOULD WE
NOT ALLOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
LAW ABIDING WHOSE CONVICTIONS
ARE DECADES OLD NOT COME BACK IN
A POSITION THE COURT TO GET
THOSE SENTENCES OF THOSE
CONVICTIONS REDUCED TO
MISDEMEANOR. I JUST THINK THAT
IS ILL CONCEIVED AND LARGELY- I
DON'T WANT TO SEE DISINGENUOUS
BUT- I THINK OF THE PUBLIC
REALLY KNOWS THE TRUTH ABOUT ALL
THESE THINGS THEY CONTINUE TO
VOTE FOR- THERE WAS AN
INITIATIVE JUSTIN LAST THE LAST
YEAR'S ELECTION. THAT 62% OF THE
PEOPLE VOTED FOR SO. IT WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE FOR THAT AND
MANY OTHER REASONS. YEAH THANK
YOU FOR A- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN- CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SAM LEWIS AND I'M THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE FIVE NINE
NINE. KERN IN EXISTING RETAIL
THEFT STATUTES ALREADY ALLOW
PROSECUTORS BRING FELONY CHARGES
AGAINST ANYONE WHO WAS ARRESTED
FOR CARRYING OUT THESE TYPES OF
THIS. ASK OUR VOTERS TO GET
TOUGHER ON CRIME DOES NOT GIVE
ANYONE THE OPPORTUNITY TO FOCUS
ON HEALTHCARE SOLUTIONS THAT
STILL HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEFT CRIMES. MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS AT ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION KNOW FIRST HAND HOW
INCREASED PUNISHMENT OF
INCARCERATION DO NOT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFER BUT HAVE HAD
SEVERE LONG LASTING EFFECTS ON
OUR COMMUNITIES. A. R. C.
MEMBERS KNOW FIRST HAND THE
BALLOTS THAT THAT THAT VERSE
OUTCOMES OF TOUGH ON CRIME THAT
LEGISLATION MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDE MYSELF SERVE LONG PRISON
TERMS BECAUSE OF THOSE
LEGISLATION. BUILT ON THE FEAR
OF RISING CRIME. OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ALSO BENEFITED FROM
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN AND BOTH
SENTENCE REDUCTION AND THE
CHANCE TO HAVE THEIR RECORDS
EXPUNGED OR RE ENTRY. THIS
OPPORTUNITY HAS LED MANY R. C.
MEMBERS INFORMED INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN GENERAL TO
SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATE BACK INTO
SOCIETY BY GIVING THEM HOPE AND
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
THIS REENTERING PROCESS.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
BENEFITED FROM PROGRAMS A PROP
FORTY SEVEN SAVINGS SUPPORTED
SUCH AS DRUG TREATMENT. IN A
HEALTH AND MANY OTHER VITAL
RESOURCES THESE SERVICES ARE
USED BY PHONE AND COURSE RATED
PEOPLE THAT PROVIDE NOT ONLY
INCOME BUT OUTCOMES. I'M AN
EXAMPLE OF NOW BECAUSE- BETTER
STABLE LONG JOURNEY SECOND LONG
TERM AND FOR FEEL CAREERS THE
LAST THING I'LL SAY IS SOME OF
THE MOST CONSERVATIVE TOUGH ON
STATE CRIMES HAVE HIRED DIVIDING
LINES IN CALIFORNIA- AND PROPS
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN TEXAS
WAS AT ONE ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND SINCE TO RAISE THE
BAR AND IT HAS SINCE RAISED
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED.
TEXAS IS A TOUGH ON CRIME STATE
SOUTH CAROLINA AND EVEN MORE
SPACE IN THAT AGAIN AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID THIRTY NINE OTHER
STATES HAVE A FELONY THEFT THE
US FROM THE THREAT OF STREP
THRESHOLD HIGHER. IN CALIFORNIA
. THANK YOU. THAT WITNESSES IN A
ROOM THERE IN OPPOSITION NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. THE MORNING IT'S
GOOD TO BE BACK- BARCODEGEORGE
OF THE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DANCING ON BEHALF
OF THE REENTRY PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA REPACK
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONLY
ST LOUIS ON BEHALF OF DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK ARAMBULA BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
FRED WILLIAMS ON HAVE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AS BINDING AS WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. AND SINCE WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD. FROM THE
TELEPHONE. WOULD NOT BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR- LET'S GO
FOR. OKAY LACKEY AND NOT SHY-
YOU NEVER. I WAS FIRST SWORE
INTO THE LEAD ON DECEMBER SECOND. TWENTY FOURTEEN. THE VERY
FIRST BILL I INTRODUCED WAS AB
FORTY SEVEN. AND IT WAS A
MEASURE TO- ATTEMPTS TO CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE PROP FORTY SEVEN. AND
THEN ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
FOUND A POSITION OF DATE RAPE
DRUGS. WE'RE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
HELLO CASUALLY WALK AROUND
ACADEMY IN ROHYPNOL FOR
RECREATIONAL USE. LET'S BE
HONEST FOLKS PEOPLE IN
POSSESSION OF DATE RAPE DRUGS
ARE PHYSICALLY TRY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF SOMEONE. WHETHER IT
BE YOUR DAUGHTER AT COLLEGE YOUR
LIFE FOR SOMEONE ELSE YOU LOVE.
VICTIMS BY NOW MORE VULNERABLE
DUE TO THE PASSAGE OF PROP FORTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT TELLS CRIMINALS
THAT THE STATE DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT JUSTICE. YOU'RE ON YOUR
OWN. DUCT TAPE REPAIR JOBS LIKE
LOWERING THE THRESHOLD AMOUNTS
FOR PETTY THEFTS ARE ADMIRABLE.
BUT THEY DON'T FIX THE ACTUAL
PROBLEM AT HAND. WE NEED A FULL
BLOWN REPEAL OF THE DANGEROUS
PARTS OF PROP FORTY SEVEN. AND I
WOULD SAY THE REALITY OF THE
OUTCOME WHETHER I DON'T THINK IT
WAS THE INTENT BUT IT IS THE
REALITY. I HAVE A DAUGHTER THAT
WORKED IN RETAIL. JUST RECENTLY
AND- SHE WAS ADVISED BY HER
MANAGEMENT THAT WHEN THEY
WITNESS PEOPLE ACTUALLY STEALING
FROM THAT RETAIL CENTER THAT
THEY'RE NOT TO EVEN BRING
ATTENTION TO THE PROBLEM MUCH
LESS REPORT. THAT'S THE REALITY
THAT WE'RE FACING FOLKS AND I
TELL YOU THAT I'M A BIT
ENTERTAINED BY. THE
OPPOSITION'S. ACCUSATION THAT
PENALTY HAS NO IMPACT ON
BEHAVIOR. THAT SIMPLY THEM WHY
IN THE WORLD WE PASSED PROP
FORTY SEVEN IN THE FIRST PLACE
OF THAT YOUR PREMISE THAT'S AT
ITS VERY FAULTY IN MY OPINION.
THE COUNT ABILITY. MAY NOT BE
WOKE BUT IT'S DESERVED AND FOR
THAT REASON I'LL BE OPPOSING
THIS. THANK YOU I LIKE THE
COLORS I GOOFED UP. I'LL BE
SPORTING AND HEART. MR FARAI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU TO ALL THE WITNESSES TODAY.
PROP FORTY SEVEN PAST SEVEN
YEARS AGO IT WAS A FIRM BY
VOTERS AND IT WAS REAFFIRMED.
THROUGH THE OPPOSITION OF PROP
TWENTY JUST LAST ELECTION CYCLE
. CRIME IS DECLINE SINCE PROP
FORTY SEVEN PASSED. AND EVEN
WITH A SLIGHT BUMP LAST YEAR WE
ARE STILL NEAR FORTY YEAR
HISTORICAL LOWS. AS WAS
MENTIONED BY OUR WITNESSES HERE
THIRTY EIGHT STATES THIRTY NINE
STATES HAVE A HIGHER FELONY.
THRESHOLD THAN EVEN CALIFORNIA
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY THE
PROGRESSIVE ALABAMA IS THAT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED. GEORGE'S AT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED TEXAS REYES
THERE'S TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
COVED WRECKED COMMUNITIES IT
TOOK PEOPLE'S BUSINESSES TO
PEOPLE'S HOMES TO PEOPLE'S LIVES
. IT'S NOT PROPERTY CRIME THAT'S
RISEN IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS IT'S POVERTY IT'S STRUGGLE
WITH DESPERATION I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LANCASTER THAT
DUCT TAPE MEASURES TO TRY TO
REPAIR THESE HARMS ARE GOING TO
DO ENOUGH WE NEED A FULL SCALE.
ATTACK IN THAT ATTACK HAS TO BE
ROOTED IN GETTING PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES GETTING PEOPLE
ECONOMIC MOBILITY GETTING PEOPLE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. WE ARE NOT
GOING TO GET THAT BY SPENDING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR TO INCARCERATE PEOPLE FOR
STEALING LESS THAN ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WORTH OF GOODS. THAT'S
HOW WE GOT INTO THIS PROBLEM AT
LEAST TAXPAYERS ON THE HOOK TIME
AND TIME AGAIN IT'S HOW WE IN
THE UNITED STATES CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE WORLD GRATION WE OUT
INCOME RIGHT SOME OF OUR CLOSEST
PEERS CHINA RUSSIA. IN
CALIFORNIA WE STILL SPEND
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
INCARCERATING EVEN NOW WITH THE
PASSAGE OF PROP FORTY SEVEN. BUT
PROP FORTY SEVEN HAS. GIVEN A
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
COST SAVINGS COST SAVINGS THEY
HAVE BEEN REINVESTED IN THE
COMMUNITIES. THERE'S OVER A
DOZEN TRAUMA CENTERS THAT HAVE
COME UP BECAUSE OF PROP FORTY
SEVEN. THE VICTIM SERVICES THAT
HAVE INCREASED BECAUSE OF PROP
FORTY SEVEN. IT WAS SMART
STRATEGIC. EVIDENCE BASED AND
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS NOW'S NOT
THE TIME TO GO BACKWARDS. NOW
IT'S TIME TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES THE MOVE FORWARD IN THOSE
ROOT CAUSES. WE NEED COST
SAVINGS TO ADDRESS PROP FORTY
SEVEN REPEALING IT WOULD ROLL US
BACKWARDS. I URGE THIS COMMITTEE
IN MY COLLEAGUES TO STAND WITH
ME IN OPPOSING THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU. IS THIS YEAR. THANK
YOU. GOOD TO SEE MR HOFFMAN I
KNOW YOU DON'T RECOGNIZE MAY HAD
HERE MORE LIKE MR KILEY WHEN YOU
SAW ME LAST LIKE WAS LIKE WORK.
THANK YOU- ANYWAY FIVE I THINK.
THAT I GO BACK TO THE PREMISE OF
PROP FORTY SEVEN WHEN IT WAS
PRESENTED TO THE VOTERS. SAFE
COMMUNITIES AND SCHOOLS. THAT'S
WHAT THEY VOTED ON THAT'S WHAT
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE VOTING ON
. AND THIS HAS NOT RESULTED. IN
THAT IN FACT WHAT HAS RESULTED
IN THAT IS THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED THEY GET OUT AND
THEN THEY CONTINUE TO GO DOWN
THE PATH. OF COMMITTING CRIMES
AND THOSE CRIMES ARE COMMITTED
AGAINST WHO. ALLOW LIVE BY LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO. FIX THIS PROBLEM BY
ALLOWING LOW LEVEL DRUG OFFENSES
WHAT WE CALL LOW LEVEL DRUG
OFFENSES TO BE TO MANIFEST
THEMSELVES INTO PEOPLE. WHO CAN
NO LONGER CARE FOR THEMSELVES
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN A CONSTANT
DRUG INDUCED PSYCHOSIS. SO NOW
WE HAVE FAR MORE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THAN WE EVER HAD IN A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE. ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN THIS DRUG INDUCED
PSYCHOSIS BECAUSE GUESS WHAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SIGN UP FOR
THOSE BADLY NEEDED
REHABILITATION FACILITIES AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET BETTER
IN THIRTY DAYS I'VE SEEN THAT
CYCLE. AS A PARAMEDIC IN
INGLEWOOD. I GOT TO GO ON PEOPLE
THEY WOULD GET ARRESTED FOR
BEING ON HEROIN OR DOING THOSE
TYPE OF DRUGS THEY WOULD GO
THROUGH THE PROGRAM. I GUESS
WHAT THEY'RE RIGHT BACK ON THE
STREETS THIRTY DAYS LATERAND
I'M GIVING HIM NOR CAN SO THEY
CAN LIVE AGAIN. FOR NOT HELPING
THOSE FOLKS OUT BY NOT BY BY
ABIDING BY THIS PROP FORTY SEVEN
IT DID NOT HELP THOSE PEOPLE AT
ALL IT'S NOT GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HELP PEOPLE. SO WHAT WE
REALLY NEED IS FOR THE VOTERS
WHO THOUGHT THEY WERE GETTING
SAFE COMMUNITIES AND SCHOOLS TO
BE ABLE TO RECONSIDER WHETHER
THAT IS THE END RESULT OF A
POLICY THAT THEY SAID- WE BUY IT
WE YEAH WE WANT SAFE COMMUNITIES
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T GET
IT. AND NOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
REALLY UPSET. AND WHETHER YOU
THINK THEY'RE AT THEIR I'M
JUSTIFIED OR NOT. I THINK GIVING
THEM THE SECOND OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE A REALLY GOOD LOOK AT THE
PARTS OF PROPER FOR PROP FORTY
SEVEN THAT THEY MAY NOT AGREE
WITH AND IF THERE ARE PARTS IF
THEY DO THEN YOU KNOW WHAT WE
CAN HAVE A WE CAN HAVE ABILL
THAT THAT ADDRESSES THOSE. BUT
YOU CANNOT SIT HERE AND TELL ME
THAT PROP FORTY SEVEN HAS NO
EFFECT ON CRIME. OR RECIDIVISM.
THE ONLY RECIDIVISM IT HAS AN
EFFECT ON. IS ONCE SOMEBODY GETS
OUT OF PRISON THEY JUST SAY. ANY
CRIMES ARE THE CRIMES YOU COMMIT
BELOW THIS LEVEL FROM NOW ON
WE'RE NOT GOING TO REALLY
CONSIDER. YOU KNOW GETTING YOU
BACK INTO AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE%
WE CAN FIX YOU WHAT NEEDS FIXED
IS THE ENVIRONMENT. THE
INCARCERATION ENVIRONMENT YES
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT CAN BE
REHAB AND WE NEED TO FIX THAT.
BUT WE DON'T WORK ON THAT AT ALL
. SO I THINK THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP IN RECOGNIZING WHAT THE
REAL PROBLEM IS AND THAT PROBLEM
IS WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
REHABILITATE PEOPLE THE RIGHT
WAY. EVEN IF THEY DON'T WANT.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WE'RE DOING
THEM A DISSERVICE WE'RE DOING
EVERY LAW ABIDING CITIZEN WHO
BECOMES A VICTIM AND I DON'T
CARE IF THAT MEANS SOMEBODY
BROKE OUT YOUR WINDOW. THEY ARE
BECOMING A VICTIM AND THEY'RE
SICK AND TIRED OF IT. I HEAR HIM
ALL THE TIME. LIESER IS SICK AND
TIRED OF IT. SO THAT'S WHY I AM
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS. IS
THAT RIGHT RIGHT M. SPORT YES.
BECAUSE I WANT THIS I WANT US TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT THE REAL PROBLEMS
ARE IN OUR SYSTEM AND FIX THOSE
AND STOP IGNORING THOSE PARTS OF
IT. BECAUSE WE DO THAT I THINK
THEN WE HAVE A MUCH BETTER
OPPORTUNITY. DECORATE BETTER
HUMAN BEING BETTERS BETTER
CITIZENS JUST LIKE THIS
GENTLEMAN HERE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BONTA. I THINK THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS THAT
WE FOR DECADES HAVE BEEN OVER
INCARCERATING AND UNDER
REHABILITATING THE FACT THAT
WE'VE ONLY SPENT- IN OUR CDC ARE
BUDGET 1% OF OUR BUDGET TOWARDS
REHABILITATION IS ACTUALLY ONE
OF THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE ISSUE
NOT WHETHER OR NOT PROP FORTY
SEVEN EXISTS AND PROP FORTY
SEVEN STILL DOES ALLOW AND
DOESN'T PREVENT PROSECUTORS FROM
CHARGING WHO WHEN WE PARTICIPATE
IN ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT FOR
FOUGHT WITHOUT. END AND FOR THAT
REASON I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO. AT REPEAL. OF A
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED BY
VOTERS. IN TWENTY TWENTY AND FOR
THAT REASON I AM GOING TO OPPOSE
THIS LEGISLATION. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. YOU MAKE CLOSEST KILEY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- I-
YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED AT AS
WITNESSES ON BOTH SIDES ON
TESTIFIED TODAY- I DO NOT EXPECT
ALL MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
FULLY ADOPT MY WORLD WORLD VIEW
WHEN IT COMES TO MATTERS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE- BUT I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU TO FOR- TO THE JUDGMENT OF
OUR TWENTY GENERAL ROB BONTA.
WHO SAID THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
CHANGES I'D PROP FORTY SEVEN IN
ORDER TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE TO
ADDRESS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
IN FACT WHAT I'M ASKING IS EVEN
MORE MODEST THAN THAT IT'S
SIMPLY THAT YOU YOU DON'T NEED
TO SUPPORT GUY OVERTURNING PROP
FORTY SEVEN ALL I'M ASKING IS
THAT YOU GIVE VOTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE SIDE THAT
MATTER FOR THEMSELVES OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS HERE SAID
THAT HE BELIEVES THAT VOTERS-
WOULD SUPPORT PROP FORTY SEVEN
AGAIN. OKAY LET'S HAVE THAT
DEBATE LET'S GIVE THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE THANK YOU AND- I DO
BELIEVE WE DO NEED TO HAVE TO
DISCUSSION- AS SOMEONE. THAT HAS
THAT CAME IN. WITH AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. AND PLANS TO LEAVE
WITHIN ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA. I
THINK I KNOW HOW TO BOXES. THANK
YOU. I WORK WITH. D. A. BONTA TO
LEGALIZE CANNABIS HERE INSTEAD
OF CALIFORNIA SO I KNOW WHERE
HIS HEART IS AND WHAT WHAT HE
MEANT. AND WHAT HE REALLY MEANT
WAS WE SHOULD BE GOING FROM HERE
. FEAR IS SO POWERFUL FEAR HAS
BEEN DRIVING LAW ENFORCEMENT
POLICIES PROCEDURES STRATEGY FOR
CENTURIES WE'VE GOT TO STOP THE
WHEELS OF JUSTICE KEEP GOING UP
AND DOWN LIKE THAT YOU'RE
STATING THE FEAR POLL RIGHT NOW
IT'S NOT HAS SWUNG IN THE SIDE
OF TOUGH ON CRIME. AS SOON AS
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER TO DOES
SOMETHING REALLY HORRENDOUS GOOD
AFTERNOON AMERICAN OR A
DEPORTATION OF LATINOS GOING
GROW UP IN A RICE IN AUGUST AND
THE FEAR OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
APPROVAL. WE CANNOT BE ON THE
SEASONAL GOING BACK AND FORTH WE
NEED TO STOP WE CHECKED WE ALL.
AGREE I WENT TO A MEETING WITH
MY- LET. AT MR LACKEY SAID YOU
KNOW HOW I FEEL RISEN ROOM FULL
OF ALL. LAW ENFORCEMENT N. B.
I'M FOR ALL OF AMERICA WHERE WE
- CHIEF OF SHARE. AND THEY WERE
TELLING ME HOW PROP FORTY SEVEN
DIDN'T WORK. AND THEY WERE BURKE
RATING WHAT WE HAD VOTED ON. AND
GUESS WHAT I UNDERSTOOD THAT MR
LACKEY SAID NOW YOU KNOW HOW I
FEEL. AND IT IT WHAT IT
EXPRESSED TO ME IS. WE'RE NOT
WORKING ON THIS PROBLEM IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY. WE'RE TALKING
AT ONE ANOTHER. I WISH WE COULD
MAKE A LAW. RIGHT NOW WE GET.
MISTER MISTER LEWIS MISTER
HOFFMAN PUT HIM IN A ROOM WITH
MR DICHAS AND MISTER PEARSON IT
HAD WORKED OUT A COLLABORATIVE
JOINT IDEA OF HOW WE SOLVE CRIED
AND HOW WE HOW WE WORK TO MAKE
PROP FORTY SEVEN BETTER. THIS
BILL THROWS THE BABY OUT WITH
THE BATHWATER IT DOES NOT GIVE
THE CITIZENS AN OPPORTUNITY AND
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH ANYONE.
THAT HAD DIFFERING VIEWS ON
PROPERTY SEVEN. IN A WAY WE CAN
MAKE IT BETTER NOT ELIMINATED
NOT GET RID OF IT NOT DEMONIZED
IT. WE NEED TO MAKE IT BETTER SO
THAT IT DOES WORK FOR WHAT
PEOPLE WANTED TO BE. A LOT OF US
BECAUSEWE DID NOT PUT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE IS AB ONE
OH NINE STEPS STARTED THIS UP
INTO NINE WE NEVER REALLY
INVESTED. THE MONEY PROPERLY IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT IS
HOUSING. DRUG TREATMENT. MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT GETTING PEOPLE
JOBS GETTING EDUCATED. LET ME
TRIED THIS THIS COURT AGREED
THAT. I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EITHER GO TO
JAIL. ARE YOU GOING TO DRIVE YOU
HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH. WE DID IN
L. A. COUNTY YOU KNOW WE GOT.
THE LARGEST MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY IMAGE AND THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. THE SHERIFF IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT EQUIPPED AND
SHOULD THEY BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT BECAUSE OF THESE
TOUGH ON CRIME LAWS. THAT'S WHAT
WE ENDED UP WITH YES SHE GOT HIM
OFF THE STREET OUT OF SIGHT
THEREFORE FOR WEALTHY AMERICA
THEY MADE TO MAKE YOU FEEL
BETTER. AND GIVE YOU SOME SENSE
OF PRIDE BUT IT ALSO
INCARCERATED MANY POOR BLACK AND
BROWN FOLKS AND TOTALLY
DECIMATED. DECIMATED AREAS RILEY
LIKE SOUTH LA EAST LA AND OTHER
PLACES. AND SELL LESS BLAMING
ONE ANOTHER. AGAIN I WISH I
COULD MAKE A LAW. THE FORCE BOTH
SIDES GET HIM IN A ROOM I
THOUGHT WHEN WE WERE SITTING
WITH MR LACKEY AND I'M- IT IT
WAS THE FIRST TIME LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAD EVER COME IN
MASS TO TALK TO ME. ABOUT HOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GETTING RID
OF PROP FORTY SEVEN BUT I LOOKED
AT IS HOW TO MAKE PROP FORTY
SEVEN BETTER. AND THAT IS THE
APPROACH. I THINK IF YOUR BILL
HAD GONE IN THAT DIRECTION- I
WOULD BE TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF
THAT HOW DO WE MAKE PROP FORTY
SEVEN BETTER AND WORK FOR THE
COMMUNITY UNFORTUNATELY THIS
AGAIN BECAUSE THE BABY OUT WITH
THE BATHWATER AS LIKE IT'S
SUPPORTED TODAY MESSAGES FROM
CHURCH RECOMMENDING AND THEN AND
NAY VOTE INTO THAT. RIGHT TO
START. BUT I THINK JUST. IS
STILL. FOR SOME COLLAPSE AND I
SAYING A WORD TO. SOME COOLER.
EFFORT BECAUSE IF WE KEEP
FIGHTING EACH OTHER ON BOTH
ENDS. THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT
BENEFIT OUR CRIMINALS IN THE
MIDDLE. AS LIKE TO WARN PARENTS
IN THE DIVORCE DEAL ARGUING
ABOUT IT'S BEST FOR THE CHILDREN
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THEY'RE
HURTING THEIR CHILDREN WERE
ARGUING ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
BOTH BANDS BUT IN THE MIDDLE.
THE PUBLIC IS HEARD WE ARE
HURTING THE PUBLIC ON BOTH SIDES
AND WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER TO
COME WITH. WITH LONG RANGE PLANS
WHICH IS A CRIMINAL JUSTICE PART
WHICH YOU GOTTA HAVE SOME
PATIENT IT TAKES TIME TO PEOPLE
FOR DRUG MENTAL HEALTH. AND THEN
. THIS QUICK FIX FELONIES AND
JUST LOCKING THEM UP AND
THROWING AWAY THE KEY. THAT
DOESN'T. WORK BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
SOLVE LONG RANGE SO WE NEED TO
COME TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH
WAYS. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC BUT
AT THE SAME TIME SONG. THE
PROBLEM WITH CRIME IN AMERICA.
NOT PUSH IT INTO PRISONS INTO
JAILS. OR INTO MENTAL
INSTITUTIONS. SO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. I'LL MOVE IT. YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL ON AB FIFTEEN
NINETY NINE BY SEVEN MEMBER
KILEY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER NAY
LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA NAY BONTA
NAY BRIAN NAY BRYAN NAY STONE.
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO NAY SEYARTO
HI HERE TO I. I'M SORRY THE BILL
HE DIDN'T PASS THE BILL. FIFTY
MAIENSCHEIN. BUT REP MATCH. WITH
THE TWO BILLS AB SIXTEEN NINETY
EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN HUNDRED-
WHICHEVER ONE YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH STARTING WITH.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE PALACES AND
THANKING YOU. MISTER CHAIR. BEST
FOR EIGHTY SIXTEEN NINETY EIGHT
CORRECT THE- AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL PORCH
PIRACY HAS LONG BEEN AN ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA THE RATE OF THEFTS
HAVE INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY AT
PARTICULARLY NOW AS CONSUMERS
RELY MORE AND MORE HEAVILY ON
ONLINE SHOPPING. LAST YEAR AN
ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS MILLION PACKAGES
WENT MISSING FROM DOORSTEPS
NATIONWIDE AND 64% OF AMERICANS
SAY THEY'VE BEEN A VICTIM OF
PACKAGE THAT. FIRST PARRIS HAVE
BECOME MORE SOPHISTICATED AND
ORGANIZED SOME EVEN RESORTING TO
RENTING U. HAUL TRUCKS AND
FOLLOWING DELIVERY OF ANSWER
NEIGHBORHOODS. AB SIXTY NINETY
EIGHT RECOGNIZES THE GROWING
PROBLEM OF RESIDENTIAL PACKAGE
THAT BY CLASSIFYING IT AS ITS
OWN CRIME AND ALLOWING FOR A
PENALTY OF UP TO ONE YEAR IN
COUNTY JAIL OF PACKAGE THEFT IS
COMMITTED. IN CONCERT WITH ONE
OR MORE PERSONS. WITH ME AT
TODAY AND AT TESTIFIED
TELEPHONICALLY IN SUPPORT IS A
LEASE OUR CITY OF KANO WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. AND
BRUCE MACRAE WITH UPS. ARE YOU A
FAMILY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THESE ARE CITY AKON
NOW WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
AB. NINETY EIGHT AS AMENDED.
CITIES HAVE SEEN THE RISE
PACKAGE THAT THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ISSUING A STATE HOME ORDER IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CONSUMERS THINK. SHIFTED THEIR
SHOPPING HABITS ILLUSTRATING
RECORD BREAKING ONLINE SALES AND
OF COURSE DELIVERY. ORDING TO A
TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT
CALIFORNIA CITIES ACCOUNTED 430%
OF ALL STOLEN PACKAGES
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. SAN
FRANCISCO TOPPED THE LIST FOR
THE CITY WITH THE MOST PACKAGE
THAT'S WITH LOS ANGELES AND
SACRAMENTO AMONG THE TOP TEN.
ADDITIONALLY ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY TWENTY SURVEY BY LENDING
TREE. ONE IN FIVE AMERICANS
REPORTED BEING VICTIMS OF
PACKAGE THAT AMID THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS. WITH 18%
HAVING THE PACKAGE OR DELIVERY
STOLEN SINCE MARCH OF THAT YEAR.
54% OF PEOPLE EMERGED REPORTED
MULTIPLE PACKAGE THAT IN THE
PRIOR TWELVE MONTH. AND 33% KNEW
SOMEONE WHO HAD HAD A PACKAGE
STOLEN DURING QUARANTINE. IN
ORDER TO DETERMINE THE BEHAVIOR
RESIDENTS HAVE HAD TO BEAR THE
COST OF INSTALLING HOME CAMERAS
IN HOPES OF COMPENSATING FOR THE
LACK OF AVAILABLE ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES. STILL BE ISSUES
PROCESS WITHOUT THE NEED FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. I'D LIKE TO
CONCLUDE BY STATING THAT THE
STRATEGY IS ONE OF MANY
SUPPORTED BY COUNTIES IN
ADDRESSING CRIME AND ITS
UNDERLYING CAUSES. I
CALIFORNIANS HAD PUT AN END TO
IT IN RECENT YEARS TIME
ADVOCATING FOR IMPROVED SAFETY
OF ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENT. WE
REMAIN INTERESTED IN ENGAGING ON
IMPROVEMENTS TO CALIFORNIA'S
CULTURAL SYSTEM INTERRUPTING AN
ENDING CYCLE OF RECIDIVISM AND
BUILDING A COMMUNITY BASED
SYSTEM OF CARE APPROPRIATE FOR
MEETING THE NEEDS OF ALL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS BRUCE DOUBLE THE
BACKGROUND THE BIKES FOR THE U.
S. GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR UPS.
OF SPEAKING- SUPPRESS OUR
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN NINETY
EIGHT. AB SIXTEEN NINETY THE
STATUS IS THE CRIME OF ORGANIZED
PACKAGE THAT. COMBAT RAMPANT
PORCH PIRATE IT ALSO GIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEW TOOLS TO STOP
THE PACKAGE STATES. IT'S
HAPPENED TO ME IT WAS JUST
DIAPERS DIAPERS AT MY HOUSE
MAYES TOLD THEM THEY WENT DOWN
THE CORNER OPEN THE PACKAGE AND
IT ENDED UP ALL OVER THE STREET
. YOU KNOW MORE. THAN EVER ARE
DOING THEIR SHOPPING ONLINE AND
I'M HAPPY ABOUT THAT. ESPECIALLY
SINCE THE BEEN DOWN. THE GROWING
NUMBER OF RETAIL PRODUCTS
LIBERTADORES SUBSIDIES OFTEN IN
A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF THE OR THE PORCHES AT.
FORT OPETH. BOB BAKKEN STEPS ARE
INCREASING EVERYWHERE CALIFORNIA
AND THE WHICH JUST STATED IS THE
WORST. THIRTY I'M STROLLING BACK
YOU NATION BEING STOLEN
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU CHAIRED
MEMBERS WE NEED YOUR HELP TO
HELP STOP PACKAGED UP AND UP OF
SUPPORTS AB SIXTY NINETY EIGHT
ENCOURAGES ALL LEGISLATURE. BILL
ART THANKS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN IT BROUGHT THROUGH
THE BILL AND TO YOU GERMAN JONES
SAWYER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND OUR GREAT
STATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU- MISTER MCCRAE. NO. YES ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THAT SUPPORT.
YES THAT'S NOT. ANY WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE PERSON
SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST
A MOMENT. THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY HER OR-
SURE MANY GAMING WHY YOU WHICH
YOU'LL SEE SOME. BILLS EX. WHY
NOT. SIXTY SIXTY YEAR ONE IS NOW
OPEN. AND ONCE AGAIN LINE SIXTY
JUST ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS FOR
ANYTHING MINUTES KRIEGER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIX NINE EIGHT
THANK YOU. MINOR. THREE THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER STEVE MCCARTY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. CAN NOW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MISTER
FRED WILLIAMS. REALLY OKAY
DEDICA. YOUR UP. GOOD MORNING
DENIGRATE ARM ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
UP OFFICE AT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AS AMENDED WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND NOTE THAT
THEY DO MITIGATE MANY OF OUR
INITIAL CONCERNS BUT WE STILL
MUST OPPOSE. A STANDARD PRACTICE
WE OPPOSE THE CREATION OF NEW
CRIMES BASED ON THE PRINCIPLE
THAT MORE CRIMES AND HARSHER
PUNISHMENT ARE NOT THE SOLUTION
TO OUR SHARED SOCIETAL PROBLEMS.
SPECIFICALLY AS DETAILED IN THE
IN COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE
CONDUCT THIS BILL TARGETS IS
ALREADY CRIMINAL COVERED BY
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT DIFFERENT
PENAL CODE SECTIONS. WHICH
SUPPORTS OUR ASSERTION THAT OF
CRIMINALIZATION WAS THE SOLUTION
WE WOULD HAVE ALREADY SOLVED
THIS PROBLEM. HAVING TO BE A
DIFFERENT CRIME UNDER DIFFERENT
CODE SECTION IS NOT GOING TO
HAVE THE INTENDED ADDITIONAL
IMPACT INSTEAD AB SIXTEEN NINETY
EIGHT PROPOSES DOUBLING
PUNISHMENT. FOR EXACTLY THE SAME
ACT SIMPLY BECAUSE MORE THAN ONE
PERSON WAS INVOLVED. THIS
WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY EVIDENCE
IT WILL DETER THESE KINDS OF
ACTS AND AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SAYS SIMPLY EXPLAINS-
THE EVIDENCE ACTUALLY SUGGESTS
THE CONTRARY. THIS BILL DOESN'T
GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT MORE TOOLS
IT JUST GIVE THEM A BIGGER BACK
AND THAT BACK IS ALWAYS USED
MOST AGAINST THE COMMUNITIES WE
REPRESENT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
AND PEOPLE EXPERIENCING POVERTY
. WE ENCOURAGE THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL TO EXPLORE OTHER
SOLUTIONS TO THEIR STATED GOALS
OF INTERRUPTING AND ENDING
CYCLES OF RECIDIVISM AND
BUILDING A COMMUNITY BASED.
SYSTEM OF CARE APPROPRIATE FOR
MEETING THE NEEDS OF ALL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO EXPLORE ALTERNATIVES TO
CRIMINAL PUNISHMENT
INCARCERATION. TO ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS AT ANY TIME THANK YOU. HEY
DO WE HAVE ANY ONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI COMMITTEE FRED WANTED A CITY
YOU CAL ACTION WANT TO CONCUR%
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE AND
THINK OF THE AUTHOR FOR THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING ON THOSE HOWEVER FOR
SOME OF THE SAME REASON WE MUST
ALSO REMAIN IN OPPOSITION. DUE
TO THE DUPLICATIVE NATURE OF THE
OFFENSE THANK. THANK YOU. WE
PREFER NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
MARCO GEORGE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
ALTHOUGH WE COULDN'T KERR IN ON
THIS ROAD ARE MOST COMMENTS- WE
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THEM AND WE
ARE OFFICIALLY REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE A POST. CAN WE HAVE
THOSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
LAYS DOWN IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I ONE THIRTY SECURE LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI GOOD TO MOVE ON
TO LINE ONE SEVENTY THREE. ANY
HEARING YES THANK YOU MCCARTY
SHOT WITH TIME DOWN AND THANK
YOU TERRY OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. MIND.
THREE OH FIVE. THREE HUNDRED AND
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I
HAVE TO MOVE ON TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE. WHY GOOD MORNING
SUSAN REPUBLICAN REJECTED IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. SURE WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO SIGNALED
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT
. WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN. SURE YOU
HAVEN LOS ANGELES COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S UNION. I'M CALLING TO
VOICE STRONG OPPOSITION- TO
THESE BILLS SEEKING TO ROLL
BACK- THE REFORMS IN PROPERTIES
THAT. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. WITH THANK YOU.
EVERY INVESTOR COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS SEEING NONE
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR WORKING
COMMITTEE WORK ON THIS I WILL
REITERATE FOR THE RECORD THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION DID WITHDRAW THEIR
OPPOSITION- WHICH WE AND I KNOW
IT'S A SPEAKER SAID BUT- WOULD
WANT TO REITERATE THAT AS WELL
SO I THINK THIS DOES HELP- IT
HELPS A GROWING PROBLEM AND I
THINK IT'S A MEASURED REASONABLE
APPROACH. AND FOR THAT REASON I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ALLEN
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
STAFF- THE NOTE WAS HARD TRYING
TO JUST TRYING TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE RELEASED GET TO A POINT
WHERE. WE FELT THAT THERE
WOULDN'T. BE ANY HARM. TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR INTERNET TO
THE PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IN THIS
ARE GOING TO. WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
SO THAT THE TEACHERS. RECOMMEND
I'VE- BECAUSE YOURE COOPERATION
WITH THE COMMITTEE. DO WE HAVE A
MORE. HELLO I WILL SECOND. A
VECES AIRTEL'S SECOND. ON AB
SIXTEEN NINETY EIGHT BY SOME
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES THEIR IRAQI LACKEY
HI BONTA. BONTA BRIAN STAY BRIAN
ABSTAINED STONE STONE I SANTIAGO
SEYARTO I'D SAY ARE TOO HIGH.
YOUR CALL USING IT THE LADY
FORMER MEMBER. CAN YOU MAY BEGIN
WITH YOUR- WE WERE DONE ROBERT
I'M SORRY AB SEVENTEEN HUNDRED.
AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- THIS BILL SB
SEVEN HUNDRED ADDRESSES THE
PIPELINE FOR STOLEN GOODS MANY
GOOD STOLEN FROM RETAIL STORES
ARE RESIDENTIAL DOORSTEPS END UP
BEING SOLD ONLINE THREE RESELL
PLATFORMS SUCH AS CRAIGSLIST OR
FACEBOOK MARKET PLACES EXAMPLES.
WELL THESE PLATFORMS ARE LARGELY
USED ILLEGALLY SWAP AND PURCHASE
USED GOODS SOPHISTICATED TAPPED
OPERATIONS HAVE FOUND POTENTIAL
IN THE SITES TO SELL STOLEN
ITEMS AB SEVENTEEN HUNDRED WILL
HELP TO THE DISINCENTIVE EYES
CRIMINALS FROM USING THESE
PLATFORMS TO SELL TOLEN GOODS
BY PROVIDING A USERFRIENDLY
AVENUE FOR PEOPLE TO REPORT
LISTINGS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY
SUSPECT MAY CONTAIN STOLEN
GOODS. THE BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
MAINTAIN AN INTERNET WEBSITE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF RECEIVING REPORTS
OF POTENTIAL STOLEN GOODS THE
BILL FURTHER REQUIRES TECH
PLATFORMS THAT ALLOW FOR THE
BUYING AND SELLING OF GOODS TO
PROPERLY DISPLAY A LINK TO THIS
REPORTING LOCATION ON THEIR
WEBSITES AND MOBILE
APPLICATIONS. INFORMATION
RECEIVED THROUGH THIS REPORTING
SITE WILL BE SHARED WITH THE
AG'S RETAIL THEFT TASK FORCE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
APPROPRIATE ADDRESSING RETAIL
PACKAGE THEFT WILL TAKE CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK YOU AND
YOUR- YOU HAVE NO PLAN WITNESSES
YOU'RE WELCOME. THE GIRL WHO
OPEN A THE LINE FOR ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND IN
SUPPORT. AND WILL OPEN UP A LINE
FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF- AB
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED. NEVER BE ITEM
NUMBER NINE. DEAR AT ANTI YOU
CAN OFTEN APPLIED. YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE AT LEAST
ONE PERSON SIGNALED THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING ATTACHMENTS- ON
BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. TO CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE OUT TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. RIGHT IN THERE WE GO
MISTER DARLING HOFFMAN-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- CALIFORNIA
AND THE SOUTHWEST. TECH NECK
TECH NET IN PERSON. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS STILL
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF TACK THAT-
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED- WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S ATTENTION OF THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE- HOWEVER
WE BELIEVE IT'S DUPLICATIVE OF
CURRENT EFFORTS TO COMBAT
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME. OUR
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
NATIONAL CONVERSATIONS- TO
ADDRESS ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
INCLUDING AND CONVERSATIONS WITH
A LEGISLATORS- IN THIS BODY. AND
ARE WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL RETAILERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DEVELOP A
UNIFIED STRATEGY TO PREVENT AND
PROSECUTE THE STAFFS- IT'S
ALREADY AN INDUSTRY BEST
PRACTICE- TO HAVE A REPORTING
MECHANISM FOR USERS TO REPORT
SUSPICIOUS LISTINGS AND GOODS-
MARKETPLACES USE THESE REPORTS.
TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST ACCOUNTS
THAT TRAFFIC IN STOLEN GOODS AND
CLICK TO REPORT EVIDENCE- IN
ORDER. TO PROVIDE THAT TO THE
PROPER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES- HOWEVER A. B. C.
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED WILL DIVERT
THOSE REPORTS ALREADY OCCURRING-
FROM OUR COMPANY SITES TO THE
PROPOSED ATTORNEY GENERAL SITE-
WHICH WILL UNNECESSARILY
DUPLICATE THESE EFFORTS- BY
COMPILING REPORTS FROM THEIR
OWN. MECHANISMS ARE COMPANIES
CAN OFFICIALLY TAKE ACTION-
COMPILE PERTINENT INFORMATION
AND LIKE I SAID REFER IT TO
PROPER LAW ENFORCEMENT- THIS
BILL WILL COMPLICATE AND
FRUSTRATE. SOME IS ONGOING
EFFORTS APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE AUTHOR LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION BUT
FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANKS THANK YOU. AND NOW
ANYONE IN THE- PUBLIC SAFETY
ROLE. IN OPPOSITION. NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR IF YOU OPEN UP FOR
OPPOSITION. TWO AB SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED. FOR THOSE OF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO A B.
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK OKAY GOOD NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANYONE. ON A COMMON ANSWER
QUESTION ABOUT SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
. SEEING NONE. YOU MAY CLOSE
THIS MAJOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MUCHA MISTER CHAN MEMBERS AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CHAIRED
RECOMMENDED I WILL. OUT TO GET A
MOTHER MOVED. ALSEK. AB
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED BY SUMMER
MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION ISDUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER IRAQI. THE LATE YES.
LACKEY I BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN
BRIAN I STONE STONE I SANTIAGO.
SEYARTO. I SEYARTO I. THE BILL
PASSES. AND MISS AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER I
DON'T NUMBER FIFTY. FIFTEEN
WHO'S BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY AND
I WANT TO THANK HER- HE'S
PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT MORE ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY THIS YEAR WANTED
TO HEAR. FOR ONE MORNING.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS I WANNA
THANK BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY. A
BILL THAT TACKLES AN ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS ONE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. THOSE
THAT ARE MENTALLY INCOMPETENT.
THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY DOES TWO
THINGS. ONE IT REMOVES THAT HE'D
THE TENUOUS BURDEN FROM THE
DEFENSE TO PROVE THAT THEIR
CLIENT IS INCOMPETENT DESPITE
HAVING THE DIAGNOSIS FROM THE
COURT APPOINTED PSYCHOLOGIST OR
PSYCHIATRIST. AND TO IT PROTECTS
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
DEEMED INCOMPETENT FROM STANDING
TRIAL IN TOWN COMPETENCY IS
OFFICIALLY RESTORED. CURRENT
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT A DEFENDANT IS COMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL FOR A CRIMINAL
CHARGE. COMPETENCY INVOLVES AN
ACCUSED PERSON BEING ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE PROCEEDINGS AND
PLAY A ROLE IN HIS OR HER
DEFENSE. ALTHOUGH A QUESTION OF
MENTAL COMPETENCE SUSPENSE ALL
COURT PROCEEDINGS FOR DEFENDANT
. UNDER CURRENT LAW INDIVIDUALS
DEEMED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL MAY STILL BE PROSECUTED
EVEN IF THEIR COMPETENCE WAS
NEVER RESTORED. UNFORTUNATELY A
PREVIOUS RULING BY ONE SHIRT
JUDGE THAT DETERMINED THE
DEFENDANT WAS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL. ISN'T CONSIDERED IF
A DEFENDANT APPEARS BEFORE A
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA JUDGE EVEN
WHEN COMPETENCE RESTORATION WAS
NEVER ESTABLISHED. IN ADDITION
UNDER EXISTING LAW FROM A COURT
CASE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
BEFORE I WAS EVEN BORN. EVEN
WHEN THE COURT APPOINTED
PSYCHOLOGIST OR PSYCHIATRIST
STATE THAT THE DEFENDANT IS
INCOMPETENT THE COURT MUST STILL
PRESUMED THAT THE DEFENDANT IS
MENTALLY COMPETENT AND THE
DEFENDANT'S ATTORNEY MUST PROVE
BY QUOTE A PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE. THAT THE DEFENDANT
TRULY IS MENTALLY INCOMPETENT.
COMPETENCY PROCEEDINGS ARE THE
ONLY CALIFORNIA CIVIL COMMITMENT
PROCEEDING WHERE THE PERSON
SUBJECT TO INVOLUNTARY
COMMITMENT. MUST PROVE THAT THEY
ARE MENTALLY ILL IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE NECESSARY TREATMENT.
THIS LEADS TO A DISPROPORTIONATE
INCARCERATION FOR VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND OTHER UNDER
RESOURCE GROUPS WHO CANNOT
AFFORD BAIL AND ARE LESS LIKELY
TO ACCESS TREATMENT. THIS BILL
WOULD SHIFT THE BURDEN OF PROOF
TO THE STATE TO PROVE A
DEFENDANT IS COMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL WHEN A COURT APPOINTED
EXPERT INDICATES THE DEFENDANT
IS INCOMPETENT. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A PSYCHIATRIST OR
PSYCHOLOGIST EXAMINING THE
DEFENDANT'S COMPETENCE TO STAND
TRIAL TO ALSO EVALUATE WHETHER
THE DEFENDANT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION. THIS
BILL WOULDALSO REQUIRE
INFORMATION. THAT IS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE STATE SUMMARY
CRIMINAL HISTORY INFORMATION.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES THAT IF A
PERSON COULD NOT BE RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY THAT INFORMATION
WOULD BE RELEVANT IN DETERMINING
THE PERSON'S MENTAL COMPETENCY
AND SUBSEQUENT CRIMINAL CASE
UNLESS THE DEFENDANT HAS
PARTICIPATED IN MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION UNDER PENAL CODE
SECTION ONE ZERO ZERO ONE POINT
THREE SIX OR HAD THEIR CHARGES
DISMISSED AT THE END OF THE
PERIOD OF DIVERSION. AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY IS SPONSORED BY SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING TEAM
JUSTICE SAN DIEGO. THERE'S OF
THE COMMUNITY SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE SAN DIEGO UPRISE
THEATER AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDER ASSOCIATION. AND
HAS A SUPPORT FROM ORGANIZATIONS
SUCH AS THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. WITH ME TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB IN
SIXTEEN THIRTY IS GINA BURNS
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZER WITH FREE
SAN DIEGO AND MOTHER OF JEREMY
SMITH. AND NICK STEWART A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS GINA
BURNS I'VE LIVED IN CALIFORNIA
MOST OF MY LIFE I'VE BEEN A CARE
GIVER FOR TEN YEARS. FOR ADULTS
WITH MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES BUT TODAY I STAND
BEFORE YOU AS A MOTHER. MY CARE
GIVEN WORD GIVE ME SOME RELIEF
FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN GOING
THROUGH WITH MY SON JEREMY WHO
HAD BEEN IN THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM HIS ENTIRE ADULT LIFE
BECAUSE OF THE SCHIZOPHRENIA HE
HAS BEEN RECYCLED- THE COURTS.
STATE HOSPITAL AND PRISON MOST
RECENTLY JEREMY SAT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR NINE MONTHS I'M
MEDICAID BEFORE HE WAS FOUND
INCOMPETENT. TO STAND TRIAL IN
SAN DIEGO. BEING SPENT THREE
MORE MY- IN. GOOD STILL ON
MEDICAID. AWAITING A BAD AND PAT
STATE HIG IN DECEMBER IN. ONE
WEEK AT HIS ARRIVAL AT THE STATE
HOSPITAL NEAR ME PLAYED GUILTY
TO AN INCIDENT THAT OCCURRED THE
VERY FIRST DAY YOU'RE RIGHT AT
THE STATE HOSPITAL. INTERLINK
COMPETENCY TO STAND TRIAL. AND
THE PATTON STATE HOSPITAL IN THE
FIRST PLACE IT'S LIKE IT NEVER
EVEN EXISTED JEREMY ARRIVED AT
PENN STATE HOSPITAL AFTER NEARLY
A YEAR IN JAIL WITHOUT
MEDICATION NO CONTINUITY OF CARE
BUT MY SON WAS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL IN SAN DIEGO HE WAS
MOST DEFINITELY INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL IN DECEMBER TO DINO.
AS HIS MOTHER IS HOPEFUL AND
THEY NEED TO SEE MY SON RIGHT
BEING VIOLATED IN A COURT OF LAW
AND CONSEQUENCES CAN BE
ADDITIONAL YEARS IN PRISON FOR
HIS CONDITION CAN ONLY BE
FURTHER EXACERBATED IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE AT ALL IT SEEMS TO ME
THE SYSTEM IS IN HUMANE PEOPLE
WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS ARE
HUMAN BEINGS THEY DESERVE THE
SAME RIGHTS AS ANYONE ELSE
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS AND THE RIGHT TO BE
MENTALLY TREATED. WITH MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT TO BE RESTORED
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING. ME TO
SHARE THIS. THANK YOU THE NET.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICK
STEWART OATEN AND THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AS A
SPONSOR OF AB SIXTEEN THIRTY.
YEAH IT'S NO SECRET MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT CALIFORNIA
DESPITE SOME OF OUR RECENT
ADVANCES CONTINUES TO PROVIDE
FISHING CARE TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF OUR SIBLINGS
PARENTS AND CHILDREN LIVING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS- ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE IS MY BROTHER- WHO
REMAINS IN STATE PRISON- DESPITE
NUMEROUS SUICIDE ATTEMPTS THAN A
LONGSTANDING DIAGNOSIS OF
SCHIZOAFFECTIVE DISORDER. FOR
DECADES INSTEAD INVESTING IN
TREATMENT BEDS AND PERSONNEL WE
SIMPLY FUNNELED OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS INTO
CRIMINAL COURT RELYING ON JAILS
AND PRISONS TO DO THE JOB OF
DOCTORS AND TREATMENT. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE CURRENT METHOD USED TO
IDENTIFY CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
MOST SEVERE FORMS OF MENTAL
DISORDERS. THE TENTATIVE
ILLNESSES ARE SO SEVERE THAT
THEY ARE FOUND INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL. CURRENTLY
COMPETENCY PROCEEDINGS OF THE
ONLY CALIFORNIA CIVIL CMMITMENT
PROCEEDINGS FOR THE PERSON
SUBJECT TO THE INVOLUNTARY
COMMITMENT MUST PROVE THAT THEY
ARE MENTALLY ILL IN ORDER TO BE
HOSPITALIZED AND RECEIVE
NECESSARY TREATMENT. BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO STATUTORY TIMELINES
TO CONDUCTING THIS EVALUATION IT
IS NOT UNCOMMON IN FACT IS
FREQUENT FOR SEVERELY ILL
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN IN JAIL
CELLS FOR MONTHS- WAITING FOR
TRIAL TO BE CONDUCTED AT
TAXPAYER EXPENSE TO FROM WHAT
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS OF ARE
DETERMINED. THAT THEY ARE IN
FACT TOO ILL TO STAND TRIAL.
EIGHTY SIXTY THIRTY WOULD BRING
CALIFORNIA'S COMPETENCY PROCESS
COMMITMENT PROCEDURES BY
SHIFTING THE BURDEN TO THE
STATE. TO PROVE THE DEFENDANT
INCOMPETENT WHEN INDEPENDENT
COURT APPOINTED EXPERT HAS
ALREADY FOUND THAT THEY'RE NOT.
THE PROCESS ENACTED BY SIXTEEN
THIRTY IS CONSISTENT WITH BEST
MEDICAL PRACTICE AND HAS ALREADY
BEEN ADOPTED BY RED AND BLUE
STATES ALIKE INCLUDING IN
WYOMING NEBRASKA NEW YORK
DELAWARE ILLINOIS IS- AND A
DOZEN OTHERS. THE SECOND PART OF
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY WOULD WHEN A
PERSON IS NOT A CONTENT TO STAND
TRIAL AND NOT RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY TRANSMITTED
INFORMATION DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
FOR INCLUSION IN THAT PERSON'S
CRIMINAL HISTORY INFORMATION. BY
PROMOTING THE SHARING OF
RELEVANT MENTAL HEALTH
INFORMATION ACROSS COUNTY LINES
CALIFORNIA FROM THE INFORMED
JUSTIN MEDICALLY ACCURATE
OUTCOMES FOR SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS. THE FISCAL
HUMAN COSTS PROLONGED
COMPENSATED TERMINATIONS AND
LATE ACCESS TO TREATMENT
IMMEASURABLE WITH
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS ON-
POOR FOLKS OF COLOR. WITH THIS
IN MIND WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE IN
FAVOR OF MODERNIZING AT LEAST
ONE SMALL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL. HEALTH SYSTEM THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. WHEN I MOVED TO.
ANY ENTERED. AND IS SUPPORT. OF
THE BILL. A SIXTEEN THIRTY.
WEBER. DANNECKER ADAM ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN STRONG SUPPORT. YOU
FRED WILLIAMS ACO CAL ACTION IN
SUPPORT YOU. MARCO GEORGE PROP
CO SPONSOR ON BEHALF OF STE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. L. WILL GO TO THE PHONES. IN
SUPPORT. MR OPERATOR. MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN
THIS IS FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. AT A DIFFERENT
POINT IN TIME THERE WILL BE A
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. RIGHT
NOW IT IS FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WILL NOW GO TO LINE FORTY ONE.
THIS IS SERRA RAKING ON BEHALF
OF INITIATE GESTURES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BYE THREE
FORTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE FROM THINKING ANY I'M
CALLING IN SICK STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI. SIXTEEN THIRTY. LINE
THREE FORTY FIVE. THIS IS CONNOR
ROBINSON CALLING FROM TEAM
JUSTICE AND FREE SAN DIEGO
CALLING IN SUPPORT. NINE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS ALI
AND I'M FROM PLANO CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY RESIDING GALLAGHER AND
I CALL AND STRONG SUPPORT- THANK
YOU FOR. LINE. THREE FOUR. KATIE
VICE WITH THIRD SAN DIEGO AND
INJUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY. LINE THREE
FIFTY HELLO. HELLO MY NAME IS
DANNY RIOS FROM SAN DIEGO AND
REPRESENTED A PRICE PETER I CALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
SIXTEEN THIRTY THE VULNERABLE
DEFENDANTS RIGHT TO A FAIR TRIAL
THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY FIVE.
LINE. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN. LINE.
THREE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE. THREE FIFTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING DEBRUSK DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN COURT. LINE. THREE OH FIVE. ONE THREE ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
THREE FORTY FOUR. HELLO THIS IS
MY OUTLOOK BECAUSE OF THE
COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE
NEED TO GIVE THESE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THESE ILLNESSES THE
SUPPORTERS BLOG DURING THEM IN
CAGES THANK YOU FINE. THREE
THIRTY ONE. THREE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY NAME IS
MARVIN I'M CALLING FROM ELLIS PC
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE THREE FIFTY NINE. MY NAME
IS LAYLA ANDY I'M CALLING FROM
COMING TO THE COMMUNITY AND
FAMILY ECHO CALIFORNIA AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT. BY. TWO
SEVENTY TWO. SEVENTY TWO YEAR
ONE IS NOW OPEN. LINE. THREE
FIFTY THREE. YEAH HI THIS OUR
SHOWCASE FROM CANYON I FOUND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. BY THREE
THIRTY. HI THIS IS MARISSA
FRIENDS FAMILY HERSH CALLING
FROM SAN DIEGO AND I'M A LOT
QUICKER A PRICE PETER I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY. LINE. THREE
SIXTY. CAMERA LAW FROM SAN DIEGO
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVISER JOB RIGHT
THERE I COMMON STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI SIXTEEN THIRTY
VULNERABLE DEFENDANTS RIGHT TO A
FAIR TRIAL. BY TWO NINETY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOHN LEE
AND I'M WITH WE THE PEOPLE SAN
DIEGO AND YOU CAN GET THIS OF
SAN DIEGO CALLING IN TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL A. B. FIFTEEN
THIRTY. AND AS A REMINDER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
STILL AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR FILE.
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK TO SUPPORT. GOING TO GO TO
LINE THREE THIRTY NINE. HI I'M
JEFF YEAH VOEPEL FINANCIAL.
EIGHT BY THREE THIRTY NINE IF
YOU WANT TO REPEAT YOU CUT IN
AND OUT. YEAH ARE YOU MIGHT. END
UP CALLING FOR THE. WHY. THREE
SIX TWO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
BRIAN KAREM I'M RESIDENT OF
WALKING KEEP YOUR TOP SCHOOL
NUMBER OF THREE AND CHANGE
INDIGO I CALLED STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SIX IN THIRTY. BURNS.
BY THREE- OH FIVE. HELLO YOUR
YES. ESPECIAL AND I'M CALLING
FROM A KILLING AND DEATH IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF GINA BURNS IN
AB. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN. BY THREE
SIXTY THREE. HELLO. YES SIR
LINES OPEN UP HI MY NAME IS
MERION XIN THEN AND FRIENDS AND
EAGLE COUNTY AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB ONE SIX
THREE ZERO. TO CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE WHO IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU-
WE'RE NOW IN OPPOSITION MR
ANYONE IN A ROOM AND- RIA. IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
NICE TO BE HERE IN PERSON AFTER
SO LONG MY NAME IS KIM STONE
WITH STONE ADVOCACY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN
RESPECTFUL- OPPOSITION
CALIFORNIA CASE LAW HAS LONG
HELD THAT THE DEFENDANT IS
PRESUMED TO BE MENTALLY
COMPETENT UNLESS THAT DEFENDANT
PROVES OTHERWISE- JUDGES ARE
REQUIRED UNDER PEOPLE VERSUS
WHAT DRIVE TO VALUATE THE
COMPETENCY OF THE DEFENDANT IF
EVIDENCE REQUIRES THAT THIS BILL
UPENDS THAT PRESUMPTION SO THAT
IF DEFENDANT ONCE FOUND
INCOMPETENT WOULD BE FOREVER
PRESUMED TO MAINTAIN THAT
INCOMPETENCE REGARDLESS OF ANY
OF RECOVERY OR TREATMENT THAT
THAT DEFENDED MAY- HAVE.
OCCURRED THE FINDING OF
INCOMPETENCE DOESN'T MEAN THAT A
DEFENDANT COULDN'T BENEFIT FROM
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
INCOMPETENCE MEANS THAT THE
DEFENDANT IS UNABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHARGES AND
UNABLE TO ASSIST IN THEIR
DEFENSE- THIS BILL- THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS FEAR THAT THIS BILL
WILL TAKE RESOURCES- FROM
POTENTIAL ALREADY SCARCELY SORT
RESOURCES FROM POTENTIAL
TREATMENT- TOWARDS EVALUATION
AND WILL REDUCE. JUDICIAL
DISCRETION AND THEREFORE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEW WILL NOT
VOTED OF THE PHONE LINES ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- AT&T
OPERATOR YOU MAY OPEN UP LONG.
MISTER CHAIR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO LINE THIRTY SEVEN. HELLO AND
YET THEY ARE STILL WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
CHIU TWENTY EIGHT AMENDED
VERSION OF THE SPELL WE ARE-
LOOKING AT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH TO ADDRESS SOME
OF OUR CONCERNS AND TAKING A
LOOK AT WHETHER THAT WOULD
CHANGE OUR POSITION BUT BUT WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE TO TWENTY
EIGHT PERCENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE. THREE SIXTY ONE.
HELLO MY NAME IS MATTHEW GRECO
HI I WAS ON A MEMBER OF THE
STATEWIDE INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL SALUTE. INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL SOLUTIONS WORK GROUP
THAT WAS SET UP BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND I OPPOSE AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY THANK YOU. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU WE'RE NOT GOING TO BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR-
CONCERNS. SCENE NINE YOU MAY
CLOSE. WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE FOR LISTENING
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL WHO HAVE
COME TO SPEAK AND SUPPORTS AND
ALSO THOSE WHO CAME TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION I DO WANT TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING FROM THE AT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S REPRESENTATIVE- SHE
MISSPOKE PERHAPS- THEY DIDN'T
GET OPPORTUNITY TO READ THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THAT COMMITTEE.
BUT THIS PRESUMPTION DOES NOT
APPLY IN MISDEMEANOR CASES NOR
IF A PERSON HAS HAD THEIR
CHARGES DISMISSED AT THE
CONCLUSION. OF A PERIOD OF
DIVERSION PURSUANT TO
SUBDIVISION E. F. SECTION ONE
ZERO ZERO ONE POINT THREE SIX.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
RECOGNIZES THE GREAT SOCIETAL
HARM AND HUMAN COSTS TO TRY AND
CONVICT THOSE WHO ARE UNABLE TO
FOLLOW OR PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCEEDINGS THAT DETERMINE THEIR
FATE. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
ENCOURAGES TIMELY ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AND
ESTABLISHES PROTECTOR PROTECTIVE
PROCEDURES. DESIGNED TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF DUE PROCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND AND THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND WE WORKED HARD TO THE CLEAR
FIVE. EVERYTHING I WAS BROUGHT
UP SO CHAIRS RECOMMENDED IDOL IS
OUR MOTION. AND MISTER MISTER
WHO MOVED. STRONG MOVED CHECK IT
CALL ROLL. ON SIXTEEN THIRD BY A
SOME MEMBER WEBER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI LACKEY
NOT VOTING BONTA HI BONTA HI
BRIAN BRIAN I STONE STONE I
SANTIAGO. SEYARTO SEE OUR TURN
NOW. MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS
ONE MORE THANK YOU. I WOULD NOT
GO TO MEMBERS. BUT WE DON'T DO
CONSENT. YES RESCUE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OUR ITEM NUMBER THIS
IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR I
NUMBER TWO AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BOERNER HORVATH VESSELS PUBLIC
SAFETY ACTIVITIES ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB FIFTEEN NINETY EIGHT
BABIES CONTROL SUBSTANTIVE
PARAPHERNALIA PHENYL TESTING. I
DON'T NUMBER TEN AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY THREE PATTERSON PROPERTY
CRIMES REGIONAL CRIMES TASK
FORCE AN ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO PATTERSON
EMERGING SERVICES HIT AND RUN.
INCIDENTS YELLOW ALERT. NEEDED
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO PASS. AND
SECOND. SECOND. YOU MAY CALL
CALDERON ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
JONES SAWYER ALL RIGHT JONES
SAWYER IRAQI. LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA I BRIAN BRIAN I STONE
STONE I SANTIAGO. SEYARTO I'D
SAY ARE TÔI. GROUNDERS ADOPTED-
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE LEFT WITH.
WITH MEMBERS- BILLS SO WILL
START WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AB. SEVENTEEN OH SIX. AND
THAT WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER THREE
. CAMPUS CRIMES RESENTENCING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HELP
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS INTEND TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA VOTERS
PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
AND LEGALIZED CANNABIS FOR
ADULTS OVER TWENTY ONE. THIS
PROPOSITION ALSO CONTAIN
LANGUAGE THAT REDUCED SEVERAL
PENALTIES ASSOCIATED WITH
CANNABIS VIOLATIONS THESE
REDUCTIONS WERE MEANT TO BE
RETROACTIVE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA ENACTED LEGISLATION
MEANT TO REMOVE BARRIERS AND
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS BY WHICH
INDIVIDUALS COULD GET THEIR
RECORDS AUTOMATICALLY REDUCED
DISMISSED OR SEALED FOR ALL
OFFENSES THAT HAVE BEEN
DECRIMINALIZED UNFORTUNATELY IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO IMPLEMENTATION
REMAINS INCOMPLETE CURRENTLY THE
STATUTE LACKS A CERTAIN
DEADLINES TO ENSURE THE
COMPLETION OF THE PROCESS THIS
HAS RESULTED IN TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS NOT
RECEIVING THE RELIEF. THEY WERE
PROMISED TO REMEDY THE INEQUITY
AB SEVENTEEN OH SIX SUCH A FIRM
TIME LINE FOR COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S LOCAL COURTS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
COMPLETE THE WORK OF PROCESSING
PAST CANNABIS CONVICTIONS DEEMED
ELIGIBLE FOR AUTOMATIC SEALING.
AB SEVENTY NO SIX PROVIDES CLEAR
DEADLINES GUIDANCE AND OVERSIGHT
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET THE JOB
DONE RIGHT THIS TIME. THIS
THERE'S NO REASON WHY IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO CALIFORNIANS ARE
STILL WAITING FOR THE LEGAL
RELIEF TO WHICH THEY WERE FIRST
PROMISED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. AB
SEVENTEEN OH SIX ALLOWS PEOPLE
TO MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES
WITHOUT SERVING THE LIFE
SENTENCE OF COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES FROM HAVING A
CRIMINAL HISTORY. THANK YOU AND
AS A WITNESS WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE GREASY BURGER WITH THE LAST
PRISONER PROJECT. A CO SPONSOR
OF AB SEVENTEEN OH SIX. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GRACIE
BURGER AND I AM THE STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE LAST PRISONER
PROJECT AND ALSO A RESIDENT OF
ORANGE COUNTY. WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF SEVENTEEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA LPP IS A
NATIONAL NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT
FOCUSED ON THE INTERSECTION OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND CANNABIS
REFORM. OUR GOAL IS SECURING
FULL FREEDOM FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN CRIMINALIZED BY
CANNABIS SPECIFICALLY THROUGH
RESENTENCING RELEASE AN
AUTOMATIC RECORD CLEARANCE. AS
THE US MOVES AWAY FROM THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF CANNABIS
GIVING RISE TO A MAJOR NEW
INDUSTRY THERE REMAINS THE
FUNDAMENTAL INJUSTICE INFLICTED
UPON THOSE WITH CANNABIS
CRIMINAL RECORDS RELATED TO
BEHAVIOR THAT YOU AND I CAN NOT
ONLY FREELY ENGAGE IN TODAY. BUT
BILL TREMENDOUS WEALTH OFF OF.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WANTED
LOW LEVEL CANNABIS RECORDS TO BE
REMOVED WHEN THEY PASSED PROP
SIXTY FOUR IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED THE
STATE AND COUNTIES TO COMPLETE
THESE AUTOMATIC CEILINGS WITH AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. YET HERE WE ARE IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
STILL BEING HELD BACK FROM THE
LIVES THEY DESERVE TO LIVE FROM
RECEIVING THE RELEASE THEY ARE
ALREADY ELIGIBLE FOR UNDER THE
LAW. AS A NATIONAL LEADER IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNJUST THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
A SYSTEM OF LEGALIZATION FOR
ONLY CERTAIN COMMUNITIES. PUBLIC
POLICY IS MEANT TO WORK FOR
EVERYONE. WITHOUT THIS BILLS
NECESSARY FIX TO THE RECORD
SEALING STATUTE OUR STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO FAIL THE VERY
COMMUNITIES WHO BEAR THE BRUNT
OF THE WAR ON DRUGS TO THIS DAY
. TO BEGIN TO RIGHT THE WRONGS
OF PROHIBITION AND MAKE
LEGALIZATION ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
RESIDENTS THE ONUS MUST BE ON
THE GOVERNMENT TO REMOVE THESE
ERRONEOUS CONVICTIONS FROM
PEOPLE'S RECORDS. SO THAT THEY
MAY BEGIN TO REBUILD THEIR
LIVES. CALIFORNIA MUST BE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE ORIGINS OF
PROHIBITION AND FINISH THIS JOB
ONCE AND FOR ALL. IT'S PAST TIME
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT JUSTICE
DELAYED IS JUSTICE DENIED THANK
YOU SO MUCH. YOU HAVE BEEN ANY
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION- IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ROOM RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS DANCING
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSORS LAST PRISONER PROJECT
AS WELL AS RE PACK THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE AND SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
YOUR MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE PARENT COMPANY
BETTER KNOWN AROUND THE CAPITOL
AS KHALIFA- LARGEST CANNABIS
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANY IN THE STATE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ANTHONY WILLIAMS ON BEHALF OF
AMAZON. WE WANT TO APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD TO RESTORE FULL RIGHTS
FOR FOLKS HAVE BORNE THE BRUNT
AS YOU INDICATED- FOR THE WAR ON
DRUGS AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR-
ACTIVE. SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AMAZON.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
A LITTLE OVER HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND CONSTITUENTS OF THE SPONSORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS. HELLO I'M STEPHANIE
SHEPHERD I AM NOT ONLY A
LIFELONG SACRAMENTO RESIDENT
GREW UP COMING HERE AS THAT.
CHILD'S FIELD TRIPS EVERY YEAR
TODAY I'M HERE AS A CONSTITUENT
OF THE LAST PRISONER PROJECT
ALSO AND FORMERLY INCARCERATED
CANNABIS PRISONER AND I'M HERE
IN STRONG STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN OF SIX
THANK YOU. ONLY ST LOUIS ON
BEHALF OF DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT. CANACCORD ARAMBULA
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER PROUD TO SUPPORT
. FRED WILLIAMS ACLU CAL ACTION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINE- AT&T OPERATOR
UP FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN
THIS IS FOR SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO A ONE OF THREE SIXTY EIGHT
. PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT. FIND
THREE SIXTY EIGHT NO ONE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU JIM LINDBERG ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. LINE. THREE SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF ORIGINS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE ORIGINS COUNCIL
REPRESENTS A HISTORIC
CULTIVATION REGIONS OF TRINITY
HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO SONO MIND THE
BAD- AND THE BIG SUR REGION OF
MONTEREY COUNTY AREAS THAT HAVE
ALSO EXPERIENCED NEGATIVE
IMPACTS FROM THE WAR ON DRUGS WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
EFFORTS WITH THIS BILL.TODAY
AND ARE PLEASED. LINE. THREE
SIXTY SIX. HI DEBBIE MODEL CAN
LOOK AT THE JUSTICE GROUP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY
THREE. PARDON ME ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LIFE IS NOW OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAINFUL SO ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
ARE NOW SUPPORT AS- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN COMMITTEE
TODAY THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
LATEST GERMAN THE WISH IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. GOING TO GO
TO. JUST A MOMENT.
ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT COME UNDER
LINE THREE SEVENTY TWO. HI THIS
IS ELLEN KOMP DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA NORML ON BEHALF OF
CANNABIS CONSUMERS OF OUR STATE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU WHEN I. BRING GET WE DO WE
DO OPPOSITION. I'M KIND OF THAT
TWEENER STONE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. AS AS AUTHOR
INDICATED WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT DESERVE
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE INTENDS TO
REMOVE IT SIDE TO CALIFORNIA
JUST I'M SORRY CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
INTENDS TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
. THANK YOU. AND I THINK WE
STILL GOING TO GO ANYWHERE IN
THE ROOM ANY OPPOSITION THEY
WILL GO TO THE PHONES AT. ANY
OPPOSITION. WHAT DO WE DO THAT
WE CAN DO THAT. SO AT&T OPERATOR
MR LIAR ANY OPPOSITION. FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN THIS
IS FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. DO CHAIR NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE GOING
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR MISTER
BRYANT. THIS IS A VERY GOOD
BILL- THANK YOU SUMMER BONTA FOR
BRINGING IT BEFORE US IS LONG
OVERDUE I WILL BE VOTING YES AND
IF YOU NEED ADDITIONAL CO
AUTHORS PLEASE LET US KNOW. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. CNN YOU MAY
CLOSE. THE BURDEN OF CANNABIS
RELATED CRIMINAL RECORD
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
PEOPLE OF AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHICH WERE ON THE FRONT
LINES IN THE WAR ON DRUGS OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR THE COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES OF CANNABIS
CONVICTIONS INCLUDING AN
ELIGIBILITY FOR PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE HOUSING CHALLENGES
BARRIERS TO HIGHER EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT STRUGGLES AMONG
OTHERS THIS BILL WILL HELP
PROVIDE RELIEF TO THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE STILL
SUFFERING. THESE CONSEQUENCES
SEVERAL YEARS AFTER THEY WOULD
AND SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED RELIEF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MY BOOK AND
AN I. TO WANNA ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU- SPECIALLY ON BEHALF OF
THAT'S ONE OF THE- ORIGINAL.
FOUNDERS OF LEGALIZING CANNABIS
ALONG WITH THE DA BONTA AND VICE
CHAIR. MR LACKEY- WHICH IS LAW
REDUCE ALL RIGHT THERE. STILL
AIDING AND ABETTING BUT ANYWAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EVERYONE-
RECOMMENDATION I'VE OF. AND IT
MADE A MOTION. SECOND THE. ON AB
SEVENTEEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA THE MISSION
IS TO DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
pJONES SAWYER HI GENSER IRAQI
LACKEY I BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN
BRIAN I STONE STONE I SANTIAGO
SEYARTO HI THEY ARE TO I. THE
BILL PASSES THANK YOU IF WITH
THE SPIRIT OF THE NEXT.
FOR THE. IF YOU'RE A PAIR ON THE
NET.
THE SEATTLE YOU MAY BEGIN I
THANK YOU AUDIBLE CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COLLABORATING ON THIS BILL WITH
ME- TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. OF THE BILL.
CALIFORNIA LAW DEFINES
TRAFFICKING AS DEPRIVING ARE
VIOLATING THE PERSONAL LIBERTY
OF ANOTHER WITH THE INTENT. TO
OBTAIN FORCED LABOR SERVICES
PROGRAM PROCURER OR SELL THE
INDIVIDUAL FOR COMMERCIAL SEX OR
EXPLOIT THE INDIVIDUAL IN AN
OBSCENE MANNER. CURRENT LAW
CLASSIFIES ALL CASES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AS A REGULAR FELONY
. BUT NOT ALL. INSTANCES OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ARE THE SAME
I'M SPEAKING OF COURSE ABOUT
CHILD TRAFFICKING. UNLESS YOU'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN IT. WISE I HAVE-
IT'S HARD TO GET IT GET YOUR
ARMS AROUND HOW ATROCIOUS THIS
IS AND WHAT THE EFFECT IS ON THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE THE VICTIMS.
CHILD TRAFFICKING CASES IN
PARTICULAR SAW SHARP RISE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO I DO SHOW
THAT THE CHILDREN WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING ARE
INCREASED RISK OF SECONDARY
INJURY SEXUAL ASSAULT INFECTIOUS
DISEASES. SUBSTANCE MISUSE
MALNUTRITION MAJOR DEPRESSION
ANXIETY POST TRAUMATIC STRESS
DISORDER AND SUICIDE IT'S HARDLY
A WAY FOR THEM TO SET UP BEING
SUCCESSFUL AS A AN ADULT. AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE WHAT ELEVATE
THE CRIME OF CHILD TRAFFICKING
TO BEING CLASSIFIED AS A SERIOUS
FELONY AS OPPOSED TO ITS
CURRENT. CLASSIFICATION AS A
REGULAR FELONY. ELEVATING THIS
TO A SERIOUS FELONY WOULD
PROHIBIT PLEA BARGAINING AND
PROVIDE A FIVE YEAR SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT ON TOP OF THE COURTS
SENTENCE FOR EACH PREVIOUS
SERIOUS FELONY COMMITTED. WITH
ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY CEO
PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF
THREE STRANDS GLOBAL FOUNDATION.
ASHLEY ARE BRIAN TO TALK ABOUT
HER EXPERIENCE COMBATING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND I BELIEVE SHE'S
ON THE LINE. I'M HERE CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES MY BRYANT BEGAN
BUT NEVER OKAY. YES THANK YOU
AND CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ASHLEY BRYANT AND THE CO
FOUNDER PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THREE STRANDS GLOBAL FOUNDATION
ORGANIZATION IS ACTIVELY ENGAGED
IN ANTI TRAFFICKING WORK STRUCK
PREVENTION EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. AND CURRICULUM AS WELL
AS OUR DIRECT SERVICES
PROGRAMMING OVER THE PAST TWELVE
YEARS I HAVE LED THREE STRANDS
GLOBAL FOUNDATION WITH A
DELIBERATE FOCUS ON PREVENTION
PREVENTION IS THE TACTIC THAT
GOES UPSTREAM TO STOP THE CRIME
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING BEFORE IT
STARTS. PROTECT OUR PREVENTION
EDUCATION PROGRAM HAS REACHED
OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND ADULT AND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND YOU ACROSS SIX STATES
HEY I'M QUICKER THAN POWER
PROGRAM HAS REACHED OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SURVIVORS. AND
IRIS CLIENTS IN SACRAMENTO AND
SAN FRANCISCO. HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IS THE EXPLOITATION OF HUMAN
THROUGH FORCE FRAUD AND COERCION
FOR THE PURPOSES OF A COMMERCIAL
SEX OR FORCED LABOR FOR THE
BENEFIT. OF THEIR TRAFFICKERS
ACCORDING TO THE ILO
INTERNATIONAL LABOUR
ORGANIZATION THERE ARE TWO
MILLION CHILDREN GLOBALLY THAT
ATTRACTED EVERY YEAR INCLUDING
AN ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND UNITED STATES. HEY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HIDES IN PLAIN
SIGHT IT IS A CRIME THAT
GENERATE OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
BILLION GLOBALLY. IT IS ONE OF
THE FASTEST GROWING AND MOST
LUCRATIVE IN SERIOUS CRIME
TRAFFICKERS PREY ON ARE
VULNERABLE AND BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT STOP THEIR TACTICS.
CALIFORNIA IS ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
BECAUSE OF FACTORS SUCH AS LARGE
A LARGE RUNAWAY FOSTER. AND
HOMELESS YOUTH POPULATION A
LARGE ECONOMY PROXIMITY TO
INTERNATIONAL BORDERS.
SIGNIFICANT IMMIGRATION
POPULATION DIVERSE YOUTH
POPULATION EXCEPT TRY IN TWENTY
TWENTY MORE REPORTS WERE MADE TO
THE NATIONAL. TRAFFICKING
HOTLINE THAN ANY OTHER STATE
COMMENT FROM CALIBER IN
CALIFORNIA 20% OF THOSE INVOLVED
AT LEAST ONE MINOR. CALIFORNIA
HAS THE TOP THREE CITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES AND SECOND PLEASE
GOING CAN YOU GO. THEY'RE ALL
**** HIGH INTENSITY AREAS FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. OF ARGUES. I
THREE TRANSFER FUNDING WE HAVE
THE HONOR WORKING IN SCHOOL WITH
AS- AND ARE USED TO PROVIDE
TRAFFIC. AND FOR HE ALL TOO
OFTEN A THE X. OF MINOR BOTH ON
MY AND IN PERSON. IN FACT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR MISSING AND
EXPLOITED CHILDREN REPORTED IN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT AND THAT TO
THEIR CYBER TIP LINE THAT THEY
RECEIVED MORE THAN TWENTY ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION REPORT UP
FROM SIXTEEN POINT NINE NINE
YOUR PART IN. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND THOSE REPORTS
IN TWENTY TWENTY. ON THE PUBLIC
AND TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION WERE FROM ELECTRONIC
SERVICE PROVIDERS. REPORTS OF
ONLINE SEXUAL EXPLOITATION OF
ARE YOU. MORE THAN DOUBLED IN
TWENTY TWENTY OUR CHILDREN ARE
TARGETS OF SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE
EMPLOYED WITHIN POWER PROGRAM
SERVED A HUNDRED AND FORTY
CLIENTS. IN SACRAMENTO 77% OF
OUR CLIENTS WORK ON FOSTER YOU
AND 79% OF OUR CLIENTS WERE
SURVIVORS OF SEX TRAFFICKING.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION PLEA BARGAINING PLEA
BARGAINS ARE COMMONLY USED TO
SAVE TIME AND EXPENSE AND AVOID
THE UNCERTAINTY OF A TRIAL. EDA
ALSO DEFINES THE ROLE OF THE
PROSECUTOR STATING THAT THE WORK
IS TO INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY BY
PURSUING APPROPRIATE CRIMINAL
CHARGES APPROPRIATE SEVERITY THE
PROSECUTOR SHOULD TAKE TO
PROTECT THE INNOCENT AND CONVICT
THE GUILTY. CONSIDER THE
INTERESTS OF VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES AND RESPECT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AND LEGAL RIGHTS
OF ALL PERSONS INCLUDING
SUSPECTS AND DEFENDANTS. IN SOME
CASES IT'S POSSIBLE FOR A
PROSECUTOR TO DO BOTH OF THESE
THINGS BUT SIMILARLY TO OTHER
CRIMES INCLUDED IN THE
DEFINITION OF SERIOUS FELONIES
THAT IS NOT THE CASE IN CHILD
TRAFFICKING. A PLEA BARGAIN AND
THE RE QUALIFICATION OF THE
FENCES THAT OFTEN COMES WITH IT
THE TRACKS FROM THE TRUE NATURE
OF THE TANIS CRIME. THERE CANNOT
BE TWO SIDES BY DEFINITION IT IS
NOT A CRIME AND THEN POLLSBUT
ONE OF KNOWLEDGE. WE KNOW FROM
PERPETRATORS THAT THEY USE
ONLINE AND IN PERSON GROOMING
TACTICS FRAUDULENT PROMISES FOR
A BETTER FUTURE OR EVEN
PARTNERING FOR BASIC NECESSITIES
TO PREY UPON VULNERABLE
CHILDREN. WITH EXPLICIT IN
TENSION OF RECEIVING SOMETHING
IN RETURN. OVER THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS I'VE SPENT ENDLESS HOURS
WITH SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THE STORIES I'VE
HEARD THE PAIN I'VE WITNESSED
THE BROKEN LINES I'VE SEEN ARE
ALL BEYOND DESCRIPTION. THE
IMPACT AND THEIR ABUSERS AFTER
WILL EXTEND THROUGH THE
SURVIVORS LIFETIME THIS IS NOT
THE SPACE TO SAVE TIME OR
RESOURCES. FOR A PROSECUTOR TO
CONSIDER A BARGAIN WITH
OFFENDERS TO HAVE DELIBERATELY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF ONE OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE CLASSES AMONG IS
DISMISSIVE. OF THE LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF THE VICTIM AT
BEST. BUT CAN BE BETTER
DESCRIBED AS NEGLIGENCE IN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BOTH INCREASE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PROTECT YES
THAT. WE MUST CONFRONT THE CRIME
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING WHEREVER
WE SEE IT AND PUNISH THOSE WHO
COMMITTED A SERIOUS CRIME.
TRAFFICKER SHOULD NOT FULLY
ENJOY THE BENEFITS OF A PEACEFUL
SOCIETY. UNTIL THEY'RE WILLING
TO HOLD THEMSELVES IT'S ALL THE
DAMAGE THEY HAVE CAUSED. THE
MARK EVAN SOCIETY WE HAVE THE TO
REMEDY THE PAIN OF THIS CRIME IF
AT ALL. WHEN I ARISES IN TAKE
ACTION AND THIS IS AFTER A. B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE IMPROVE THE
PROCESS. RESPONSE TO CHILD
TRAFFICKING IN PER THE
PROTECTION VICTIMS IN POTENTIAL
OF. ALLOWING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAINTAIN ITS STANDING
AS A LEADER IN THE ANTI TRACKING
SPACE AND ENSURING THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM AND SO. GREG BURKE WITH A
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINGS THANK YOU
. CAN STONE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MORNING RAIN SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND POLICE OFFICER
ASSOCIATIONS OF SANTA ANA
RIVERSIDE NEWPORT BEACH CORONA
POMONA ARCADIA CULVER CITY FOR
TEN AND BURBANK ALL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
IS COURSE ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THEY'RE NOT GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE EIGHTY ANTI
OPERATOR. MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO
SIGNAL THAT YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. TO CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN GOOD MORNING
THIS WORK- GEORGE ON TH I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION TO AB. SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. AND ALTHOUGH WE ARE
OPPOSED TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING OF
EITHER MINORS OR ADULTS. WE
BELIEVE THAT INCREASING
PENALTIES IS A FAILED POLICY
THAT HAS NEITHER DETERRED CRIME
NOR PREVENTED FUTURE VICTIMS AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE IN PARTICULAR
IS UNNECESSARY BECAUSE THE UMAN
TRAFFICKING ONE NOW ALREADY
PROVIDES FOR SUBSTANTIAL STENSON
STREET PRISON EIGHT FOURTEEN OR
TWENTY YEARS. IN SOME INSTANCES
FIVE EIGHT OR TWELVE YEARS AND
OTHERS AND IN CASES INVOLVING A
MINOR WITH DURESS IS PUNISHABLE
BY FIFTEEN YEARS TO LIFE IN
PRISON. AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE
DOES NOTHING TO SOLVE THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS IN OUR
SOCIETY WHICH WE TO STATE SEX
TRAFFICKING. INSTEAD WE ASK YOU. TO ADOPTS A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH AND FOLLOW THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
RESEARCHERS THAT YOU HEARD FROM
LAST MONTH FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GOLD
SCHOOL OF LAW. WHO WERE PART OF
YOUR INFORMATIONAL HEARING. AND
THEY SAID. THAT THEIR STUDY
FOUND THAT THE UNITED STATES
OVER RELIED ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN A RETRIBUTIVE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM APPROACH TO
ADDRESS. COMPLEX SOCIETAL ISSUES
THAT INSTEAD REQUIRE NUANCED
UNDERSTANDING OF TRAUMA RACE AND
POVERTY. IN THEIR SEMINAL REPORT
WHICH I THINK THEY MUST'VE
REFERENCED THEY ASKED. FOR
MOVING THEY SAID AFFECT OF ANTI
TRAFFICKING EFFORTS ARE MOVING
AWAY FROM SUPPORT FOR USE OF
OPERATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS AND FOCUSING INSTEAD
ON COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGIES. AND INVESTING IN
POVERTY RELIEF ANTI
DISCRIMINATION INITIATIVES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES. AMONG THEIR SIX
RECOMMENDATIONS OR SUPPORT
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACHES TO IDENTIFY VICTIMS
AND TRAFFICKERS OUTSIDE OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SEVENTH SYSTEM
. STRENGTHEN PREVENTION EFFORTS
THAT REDUCE THE VULNERABILITY OF
POTENTIAL VICTIMS- I THINK ONE
OF THE WITNESS THE WITNESS AND
SUPPORT TALKED ABOUT FOSTER
CHILDREN THEY ARE VULNERABLE AND
MAY NEED ASSISTANCE INCREASED
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO VICTIMS
AND SYSTEMATICALLY OFFER
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES TO EVERY
SUSPECTED VICTIM THESE ARE
PROVEN EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES. AND
LIKELY IN ORDER TO HELP THE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
HUMAN IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING BY
SUPPORTING THEIR PROGRAMS AND
INITIATIVES. YOU CAN MEET
VICTIMS NEEDS AND I BELIEVE
COMING BEFORE YOU IS THERE'S
GOING TO BE A BUDGET ASK FOR
HOUSING. FOR SEX WORKERS AND
FORMER SEX WORKERS WHO INCLUDE
THE VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
- THEY'RE ASKING FOR A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION AND ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND MONIES. FOR A
PILOT PROGRAM TO SUPPORT FIVE.
TO TEN HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR UN
HOUSED. AND CULTURALLY. ON
COMPETENT SERVICES HOUSING IS
ONE OF THE KEY NEEDS OF THIS
COMMUNITY. ANDERSON IMPERATIVE
TO GETTING BACK ON THE RIGHT
ROAD AND TO SOLVING THE PROBLEMS
THAT LEAD TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE ON AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOBODY CAN ROOM ANY. AND IN
OPPOSITION. DANNECKER ORDER
MAMBA HALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND IN MY
INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY AS THE
DAUGHTER OF A SURVIVOR OF
VIOLENT SEXUAL HARM IN
OPPOSITION. FRED WILLIAMS ACLU
CAL ACTION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NOW GO TO PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE. ONE
TWENTY FIVE. THE MORNING SURE
MEMBERS GREGORY FELT INITIATE
JUSTICE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE ONE MORE PERSON
WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT. WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO LINE THREE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING CAN PROGRAMMING
YES THE MORNING MY NAME IS
ADRIANA GRIFFITH I AM A SURVIVOR
AND FORMERLY INCARCERATED
SURVIVOR OF HUMAN SEX
TRAFFICKING AND IN MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY AND IT'S OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER FOR INITIATE JUSTICE I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY. QUESTIONS
MR LACKEY. YEAH I DON'T REALLY
HAVE QUESTIONS I JUST HAVE- JUST
A STATEMENT ESSENTIALLY THAT-
YOU KNOW THIS THIS PARTICULAR
CRIME. AS SUCH A DELIBERATE
CALCULATED AFFRONT AGAINST
DECENCY. THAT AND IT'S MY
OPINION AND OUT I'M ONE WHO
LIVES MYSELF WITH THE VICTIM
CONSIDERATIONS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT THEY ARE SO OFTEN. JUST
OVERLOOKED AND TO SOME DEGREE
DISMISSED AND I BELIEVE THAT
BURKE WHAT THIS DOES THIS DOES
NOT. RISE THE ISSUE- OF CRIME TO
A VIOLENT FELONY WHICH IS WHEN I
WOULD EVEN PREFER. IT GOES TO
SERIOUS WHICH IS A STEP PRIOR TO
WHICH MEANS IT DOESN'T COUNT AS
A STRIKE- AND THE OTHER SOME
OTHER VERY VERY POWERFUL.
COMPROMISES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
TO MAKE THIS A US A SERIOUS
FELONY VERSUS SAY A VIOLENT
FELON AND I JUST WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T ALLOW
OF. PLEA BARGAINS IN THE
SITUATION THAT'S ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS AT THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW. BECAUSE WAIT WE
OFTEN THINK ABOUT. THE WHERE'S
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM WORKS IN
SENTENCING AND IT'S FOR THE
OFFENSE YOU'RE CONVICTED OF AND
THE MOST RECENT THAT YOU'RE
CONVICTED OF NOT ESSENTIALLY
WHAT YOU DID WHICH YOU'RE
CONVICTED OF WHICH OUR PLEA
BARGAINS OVER 90% OF THE TIME.
AND SO I THINK THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE HOLD THESE. UNIQUE
OFFENDERS TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR THEIR VERY- CRASS BEHAVIOR
AND SO I APPLAUD YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I WILL
BE STRONGLY SUPPORTING. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
CONTENT. SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- SO WHATEVER
IT IS A GIVEN THE TESTIMONY
TODAY WHATEVER THAT ATTEMPTS ARE
BEING MADE TO ADDRESS THIS. IN A
DIFFERENT MANNER THEY'RE NOT
WORKING- IF YOU WOULD GO OUT AND
ANYONE YOUR COMMUNITIES YOU CAN
FIND. HOUSING UNITS APARTMENTS
CONDOMINIUMS- THAT THE ONLY.
TOOLS ARE THE ONLY FURNITURE
INSIDE OUR MATTRESSES ON THE
FLOOR OF EACH BEDROOM EACH ROOM
AND THOSE ARE USED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF EXPLOITING CHILDREN
THEY HAVE BEEN KIDNAPPED HAVE
BEEN DRUG AND HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED INTO THIS UNDER WORLD
WORLD OF. STAY HUMAN SEX
TRAFFICKING OF CHILDREN. I HAVE
SEEN IT. I DON'T KNOW WHO ELSE
IN HERE CAN SAY THAT THEY HAVE
SEEN IT. AND EVERY TIME I SAW IT
. MY PROMISE WAS SOMEDAY I'M
GONNA TRY TO TRY TO HELP THESE
PEOPLE. HUMAN TO DRUG
TRAFFICKING HUMAN TRAFFICKERS OF
CHILDREN. ARE NOT PEOPLE THAT
ARE ADDICTED TO DRUGS WHERE WE
CAN REHABILITATE THEM THEY'RE
NOT PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO
SURVIVE AND JUST FEED THEIR
FAMILIES. THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE LOWERED TO THIS BY MAKING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. JUST LIKE
DRUG DEALERS ONE MAKE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. AND THEIR USE IN OUR
KIDS TO DO IT. THEY HAVE NO SOUL
. AND THEY'RE TAKING THE SOULS
OF OUR KIDS AND RUINING THEIR
FUTURES. BECAUSE WE WANT TO PUT
THEM BACK OUT INTO SOCIETY AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE. THIS BILL SAYS
NO WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO THAT
AND AS MR LACKEY HASSAID IT
DOESN'T TAKE IT TO THE HARSHEST
PENALTY. ALTHOUGH I MAY AGREE
WITH HIM. BUT IT TAKES ANOTHER
STEP BECAUSE WHATEVER WE'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW IS NOT WORKING
AND IF YOU THINK FAILING ARE YOU
THINK IT WAS FAILING BECAUSE OF
THE INCARCERATION RATES FAN NO
IT'S FAILING. BECAUSE THE BAD
GUYS ARE OUT THERE TAKING THOSE
KIDS AND PUTTING THEM IN THE
POSITION THAT THE RAN WHERE THEY
CAN'T DEFEND THEMSELVES THAT'S
OUR JOB AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY AND THAT'S WHY I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON SIXTEEN. SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU. DID CHURCH GOING
TO SECOND HELPING TO MILFORD.
AND CALL FOR THE VOTE. ON AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBER STATES ARE TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY HI
BONTA. BONTA NEL BRIAN NOW BRIAN
KNOWS STONE. STONE NO SANTIAGO.
SEYARTO AND BATIC HI THEY ARE
TAUGHT I. THE BILL FAILS.
I'D LIKE TO ASK. YEAH. ROBERT
AND. ECONOMIC BIGELOW. IN MY
CAREER. THERE'S NO OF. GRAT WE
CONSIDER. BY UNANIMOUS. THANK
YOU SO. WHO'S UP. NUMBER. FIVE
TO. OKAY SO THE BILL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. EUROPE THANK YOU-
MEMBERS AND SHARE I'M HERE TODAY
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESS OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
INCARCERATION AS WELL AS REMOVE
IT STIGMATIZED LABEL SOCIETY HAS
PLACED ON INDIVIDUALS WHO
EXPERIENCE INCARCERATION
CURRENTLY PROFITS FROM THE SALE
OF CANTEEN ITEMS FOR OUR MONEY
GENERATED FROM TELEPHONE
SERVICES ARE DEPOSITED INTO
COUNTY. INMATE WELFARE FUND.
PLEASE I W. APPS SHOULD BE USED
BY THE SHERIFF'S PRIMARILY FOR
THE BENEFIT EDUCATION AND
WELFARE OF THE PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
INCARCERATION. THE CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS DID ANY LEFT OVER FUNDS
MAY GO TO FACILITIES MAINTENANCE
SALARIES AND BENEFITS DEEMED
APPROPRIATE BY TO SHARE. BECAUSE
THIS DISCRETION THE MANAGER OF
THESE FUNDS HAVE BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF GRAND JURY IN CARS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SURE AN
EVIDENCE I W. HATCH HAVE BEEN
USED INAPPROPRIATELY. AS A
RECENT EXAMPLE REPORTS LAST
SUMMER FROM THE SACRAMENTO
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT USED TO
FUNDS TO PAY FOR TRIPS TO LAKE
TAHOE RESORT AND OTHERFLIGHTS
AND LODGING ASSOCIATED WITH
CONFERENCES. ADDITIONALLY
REPORTS HAVE CITED THAT IN SOME
YEARS SALARIES AND MAINTENANCE
HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR BETWEEN SIXTY
SIX TO NINETY FROM SAID THREE
PERCENT. OF THE MONEY SPENT FROM
THE FUND. WHILE PROGRAMS THAT
DIRECTLY BENEFIT INCARCERATED
PEOPLES SUCH AS THE LAW LIBRARY
AND EDUCATION ACCOUNT FOR AT
LEAST 31% WHEN THE FUNDS ARE
INCREASINGLY SPENT TO BENEFIT.
THE SHERIFF'S DISCRETION OVER
THESE FUNDS ARE USED BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF IMF'S ORIGINAL INTENT
AND AT THE EXPENSE OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. BY
REQUIRING THE FUNDS TO BE SPENT
SOLELY NOT PRIMARILY FOR THE
BENEFIT EDUCATION AND WELFARE OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
INCARCERATION AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WILL ENSURE GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY OVER THESE BONDS
THE BEST ENSURING A MORE
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY OF
INDIVIDUALS INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. FURTHER WE MUST
RENAME THE COUNTIES FUNDS AS THE
USE OF THE TERM INMATES IS BOTH
OUTDATED. AND HUMANIZING TO
THOSE EXPERIENCING CAR SERRATION
CONSISTENT WITH OUR BELIEF THAT
INCARCERATION DOES NOT DEFINE A
PERSON. WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO AS YOU SEND YOU THE YOUR SON
YEAH MNS POLICY OUT ADVOCATE.
WITH GRACE. END CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA. AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE CLUB OF THE
COMMITTEE IF ANY OF THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATES WILL BE A GREAT THING
CAL POLY IN CALIFORNIA- ENTRANCE
LOBBY CALIFORNIA HERE'S TO MATCH
IN A LIBERATED FUTURE. FREE FROM
THE SENATE RACISM AND POVERTY IN
WHICH ALL CHILDREN EXPERIENCE
THE CHILDHOOD OF ABUNDANCE
DIGNITY LOVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
THRIVE. AND TO ACHIEVE THE
VISION WE ADVOCATE FOR PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS THAT CREATE
TRANSFORMATIVE ENERGY
INTERGENERATIONAL CHANGE AND
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. WELL TO THANK CHAIR
JOHN FOR ALL A SEVENTY EIGHTY.
OF THIS WE SHOULD ALLY ON HOW WE
ADDRESS PEOPLE WHO ARE CAR. AND
FONG EXPENDED THE CAR P. WALKER
ARE SOLELY FOR THE BENEFIT
EDUCATION AND WELFARE OF THOSE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
INCARCERATION. INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CARPOOL IF. TO EXPAND. AT
THE TRAUMA. IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
IN. WHAT CURRENT INCARCERATED
THERE MUST ME PROGRAMMING AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HEALTH AND
HEALING THE MEDICAID LONG TERM
DISPARITIES BEYOND
INCARCERATION. UNDER THE
PROFESSIONALLY CHIU FORTY PARK
STREET MOTHER AND GIRL. I A
FIFTY AND PERSON AT WITH THE
WITNESS. EDIBLE STRUCK MY
FORMALLY CORPORATE LOVED ONES
JUST TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
CROSSES THE TRAUMA OF THE-
ACROSS. I KNOW THE IN THE IN A
INSTILLING PROPER FALL HEAVILY
ON SAM AFTER FORCE OF OUT MY
POST. THREE PEOPLE CRIMINAL
HISTORIES KALAU CON THAT RESULT
IN VERY TO EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
HEALTH EDUATION AND OTHER MOVED
ECONOMIC STABILITY OUT OF REACH
FOR THE IMPACT FAMILIES. AND
BARRON POINTED GENERATIONAL PA.
AND WE TAKE MEANING WAY IN
QUESTION PEOPLE TO BE. CHOIR TO.
NUMBER EIGHT HISTORY SHOULD
SHOULDN'T BE TO A LIFE OF SAN
YOU PROPERTY TRAUMA WE BELIEVE
THIS SCALABLE THE NEEDLE STRUCK
. AND PROVIDES AN OPERA TO MORE
ME PROGRAMS AN OPPORTUNE FOR SO
ADVANCE WELL PERSON IS QUESTION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. K. R.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER OF.
EXPRESSIONS OF SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COME FORWARD AND- EXPRESS THAT
SUPPORT. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
LITTLE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. PHONE OPERATOR THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT.
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE GOOD ZERO PRESS ONE
AND SERVE YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE'RE
GONNA GO LINE. THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN. LINDA WONDER WHAT TO
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SEVENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING JIM
WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. BINA.
FORTY ONE. THIS IS SURVEYED ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE GESTURES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. BY THREE SEVENTY
FIVE YOU'RE ONE IS NOW OPEN. HI
CAN PROGRAMMING YES YEAH HI MY
NAME'S ADRIANA GRANT THERE AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO. FIND THREE
SEVENTY THREE. DEBBIE MODEL GAME
WITH ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP AND
SUPPORT. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. OKAY ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. MORNING MR
TURN MEMBERS CORY CELLS ALONE WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO. AS THE
AUTHOR SAID THERE ARE STATUTORY
LIMITS ON HOW- THE PROCEEDS AND
THE FUNDS THAT ARE IN THESE
FUNDS CAN BE SPENT- THE PENAL
CODE SECTION FOUR ZERO TWO FIVE
IT'S BEEN VERY CLEARLY LAID OUT-
WITHIN THAT SECTION THERE IS
ALSO A REQUIREMENT THAT. THE
SHARE FILE AN ANNUAL ITEMIZE
REPORT TOTHE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS UPON THOSE
EXPENDITURES. THE LAW ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE EDUCATION
TREATMENT AND OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDED BY THESE FUNDS- REQUIRE
SUPPORT AND THEY REQUIRE STAFF
TO MAKE THEM HAPPEN- AS WE NOTED
IN OUR LETTER THIS CHANGE IS NOT
DONE IN A VACUUM- JUST MONTHS
AGO THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TOOK ACTION
TO CAPTURE ALL PHONE RATES ON
INTRASTATE COLES. THIS CHANGE
HAS AND WILL REDUCE THE FUNDING
SUPPORT AVAILABLE FOR THE IWS- I
NOTE THIS BECAUSE WE SHOULD
CONSIDER ALL OF THESE CHANGES
POTENTIAL CHANGES TOGETHER. WE
MUST ALSO CONSIDER THAT THE
EXPECTATION OF JAILS AND
SHERIFFS HAS CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS CERTAINLY SINCE- THE
ENACTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
REALIGNMENT. AND THOUGH THE
STATE DOES PROVIDE FUNDING- TO
THE COUNTIES- IN CONNECTION WITH
THESE DUTIES COUNTIES TOOK OVER-
SIGNIFICANT ROLE CHANGES- AND
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT THE
PROGRAMS FOR INCARCERATED
PERSONS. WILL RECEIVE THESE
FUNDS THAT COME FROM REALIGNMENT
- THE NET RESULT IS THAT THE
DEMAND FOR MORE PROGRAMS.
CONTINUES TO RISE- WHILE THE
STATE AND ITS VARIOUS FORM
CONTINUES TO ELIMINATE RESOURCES
AND FLEXIBILITY AND HOW THOSE
FUNDS ARE SPENT. AGAIN THE LAW
REQUIRES ANNUAL ITEMIZE REPORTS
ON THE USE OF THESE FUNDS THIS
FOSTERS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED CSSA MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. SHE GIVES ME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ENDING PERSONS IN
THE ROOM LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION PLEASE DO SO NAME
ORGANIZATION. THINGS CHAIR
MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALSO AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OR
OPERATOR THERE ANY- ON THE PHONE
LINES WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION. YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE AND ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE LINE OF.
THREE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
APOLOGY SUGAR OKAY- HERE BUT
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THAT
YOU'VE GOT TO CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. THE
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE. IT LOOKS
LIKE THAT'S A NO MISTER CHAIR
HEDGE YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
THANK YOU- REALLY WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT IS KIND OF CORRECT
SOMETHING THAT WE'D LAWMAKERS
DID WE DID NOT FULLY DESCRIBE
WHAT WE WANTED AND INTENT I
BELIEVE- TALKED TO OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND LOOKING AT
THE LAW. THAT WAS STOLEN AS L.
E. L. Y. FOR THE USE OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS LOSS FOR IN AND
MAYBE IN SOME CASES. THE I DON'T
EVEN USE THE WORD MISUSE BUT
THAT THE USE OF IT THAT IS NOW
DEEM INAPPROPRIATE IS BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T CLARIFY IT CORRECTLY THIS
IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR. THAT THE- FUNDS THAT
ARE GENERATED BY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IS TO BE USED
EXACTLY FOUR DOWN AND ONLY FOR
THE- FIRST BERKELEY AFT RECYCLE
. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHEN A SECOND. AN
EMOTION MOVE THE BILL. THAT OKAY
WE NOW HAVE MOTION TO
PSYCHOLOGICAL FOR QUESTIONS
PLEASE ON AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY SOME MEMBER JONES SAWYER
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI VOTERS
LACKING NOT BOATING BONTA HI
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I STONE
STONE AYE SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I
SEE ARE TO. SAY OUR TURN NOW.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT TO HAVE ANY ADD ONS OR
VOTE CHANGES. AND- I WILL BE
LEFT IN THE CALLS. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I. ITEM NUMBER ONE THIS
MEASURE WITH ON CALL AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE STONE.
STONE HI THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SIXTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB SEVENTEEN OH SIX.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. I DON'T
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FIFTEEN
NINETY EIGHT WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WAS JUST
DISPENSED WITH. I DON'T NUMBER
SIX AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE STONE
STONE NOW THE LAST
RECONSIDERATION. FOR SEVENTY
NINE NINE IN EIGHTEEN THIRTY.
FIFTY NINE NINE. WE. FIFTEEN
NINETY FIFTEEN NINETY. TWO NINE
SURE GIVEN THE FACT. RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NO OBJECT TO THE NO
OBJECT BY YEAH VOTE GIVEN
RECONSIDERATION.
ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE STONE
STONE AYE. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
SIXTEEN NINETY EIGHT THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO.
YES FACE A MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
EIGHTY SIXTEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO I
DON'T HAVE BIRD NINE AB
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I. ITEM NUMBER TEN WAS
ON CONSENT ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. ON RECONSIDERATION
ON AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE I THINK
YOU. I DON'T NUMBER FOURTEEN WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIXTEEN THIRTY
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I. THAT
INCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE THANK YOU.